Hello
Da bin ich ja ich war auf dem Klo
Leute ich merke ganz schön meine Oberschenkel ich bin vorher schon wieder meine Runde gefahren
Hat er gesagt ich dachte das ist so ein ultra krasser Rust Fan das glaube ich nicht
Windows, oh ne please, kein Windows Update ich musste ein Windows Update auf der Arbeit machen zwei Stunden konnte ich mein Notebook nicht verwenden
Aber Go ist nicht blazingly fast was ist denn Go?
Zwei Stunden ja zwei Stunden Notebook Wartung musste gefühlt 50 Mal Rebooten bis es dann funktioniert hat
Ne ne ne, Go ist nicht insanely fast wenn Rust blazingly fast ist so geht das ja nicht
Ich starte mal meine VM und mach mal Updates
Ich kann euch an der Stelle mal erzählen ich habe mein Fahrrad kaputt gemacht mein neues
Aber aber nicht aber nicht so kaputt wie das letzte Mal
Das letzte mal hat mich ja ein Auto umgefahren total schaden
nein wirklich wirklich und zwar am Wochenende
Ja wochenende wars am Wochenende
Habe ich gedacht
Ich schraub mal selbst ein bisschen
Nein nein nein der Rahmen ist nicht kaputt der Rahmen aber ich konnte jetzt ein paar Tage nicht fahren weil ich das kaputt gemacht habe und zwar
Ich dachte mir so am Wochenende also was du schraubst mal selbst ne ding nitscher
Und dannuffy
Schraubst mal selbst ein bisschen was dran rum.
Nein, 14 Tage.
Doch, 14 Tage sind schon vorbei.
Aber ich will es auch nicht zurückgeben.
Also und zwar, ich dachte mir, ich schraube ein bisschen selbst dran rum.
Ich mache mal hier Package-Updates inzwischen Zeit.
Und zwar, was ich vorhatte, ist folgendes.
Richtig.
Das erste, was ich machen wollte, ist die Kassette austauschen.
Standardmäßig ist eine 11 bis 34 Kassette drin.
Und ich wollte eine 11 bis 40 Kassette drauf machen,
sodass ich ein bisschen mehr Oma-Gang habe, wenn es den Berg hoch geht.
Das ist zwar leicht außerhalb der Spezifikation für meine Schaltung,
aber kein Problem.
Das habe ich auch zig YouTube-Videos gesehen.
Das frisst das Ding und es funktioniert.
So, Fahrradschrauber-Kurs.
Ja, es wäre vielleicht nicht verkehrt, wenn ich den auch gemacht hätte.
Zumindest habe ich mir bei der Gelegenheit gedacht,
wenn ich schon die Kassette tausche von meinem Fahrrad,
dann bedeutet das ja, die neue Kassette,
also Kassette ist das Ding hinten.
Das, was die Zahnräder, die man hinten hat an einem Fahrrad, ja.
Wer da mit den Fachbegriffen nicht so vertraut ist,
das ist eine Kassette hier bei mir.
Ja, so ein Ding habe ich auch hier, so was zum Abmachen.
Und da dachte ich mir so, ja, wenn du jetzt die neue Kassette drauf machst,
dann ist die ja ölfrei.
Doch eine Kassette setzt sich aus Ritzel zusammen.
Ritzel sind die einzelnen Zahnräder, die man drauf macht.
Und die sind dann wieder auf so einer Kassette.
Und Ritzel werden angegeben mit der Anzahl der Zähne.
Was, mittlerweile streamt man Musik? Macht man das?
Wolltest du dein Fahrrad flashen?
Ich habe mein Fahrrad geflasht!
Ich habe mein Fahrrad geflasht.
Ich habe ja eine elektronische Schaltung.
Ich habe ein Firmware-Update gemacht letztens.
Ich habe mein, ich habe, seriously, ich habe mein Fahrrad geflasht.
Kein Witz.
Aber mit der offiziellen, mit der offiziellen Firmware und der offiziellen App.
Die App ist übrigens richtig.
Dick.
Scheiße.
Anders kann ich es nicht sagen, ey.
Keine Ahnung, was sich die Highly Paid Professionals von Shimano dabei gedacht haben.
Aber die App ist richtig kacke.
Wenn du, passt mal auf.
Nur um euch mal zu erläutern, wie scheiße die App ist.
Du machst die App auf.
Connectest deine Schaltung.
Dann schließt du die App.
Oder, oder sperrst dein Telefon und lässt die zu lange inaktiv.
Dann geht deine Schaltung.
Nicht mehr.
Weil du die Schaltung nicht ordnungsgemäß disconnected hast.
Das Ding resettet sich nicht von allein.
Und die App hat dann aber vergessen, dass sie connected ist.
Dann musst du erstmal deine Schaltung wieder neu pairen und rebooten quasi, dass es funktioniert.
Das ist richtig scheiße gemacht.
Ja, richtig scheiße.
So.
Aber.
Während wir Updates machen.
Genau.
Also, was ich euch eigentlich erzählen wollte.
Ich wollte die Kassette tauschen.
Ja.
Also.
Da habe ich das dran.
Habe ich gemacht.
Und so eine neue Kassette kommt komplett ohne Öl und ohne Fett drauf.
Weil man ölt und fettet seine.
Fetten.
Entschuldigung.
Man ölt seine.
Oder.
Ja.
Seine Kassette eh nicht.
Sondern nur die Kette.
Bei der Gelegenheit habe ich mir auch noch eine neue Kette gekauft.
Und habe mir gedacht.
Weißt du was?
Ich wachs jetzt mal meine Kette.
Also nicht hier irgendwie.
Sondern richtig wortwörtlich genommen.
Und dann habe ich meine neue Kette entfettet.
Und gewachst.
Eingefädelt.
Hat auch wunderbar funktioniert.
Hoch und runter geschaltet.
Hat sich gut angehört.
War ein bisschen viel Wachs dran.
Und so.
Eigentlich alles gut.
Und dann habe ich festgestellt.
Mist.
Also ich musste auch die Schaltung ein bisschen weiter runter drehen.
Damit die 40er Kassette drauf passt.
Und so alles gut funktioniert.
Wunderbar.
Und dann gucke ich auf die Kette.
Und stell fest.
Mist.
Ich habe sie falsch herum eingebaut.
Das Video kenne ich.
Das ist nice.
Das habe ich schon geguckt.
Ich habe die Kette falsch herum eingebaut.
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Also.
Kettenschloss wieder aufgemacht.
Kette rumgedreht.
Wieder eingefädelt.
Und dann.
Und dann ist mir aufgefallen.
Mist.
Die ist ja.
Die kriege ich ja gar nicht mehr zu.
Weil.
Dann müsste ich erst runter schalten.
Und dann.
Und dann ist mir aufgefallen.
Mist.
Die ist ja.
Die kriege ich ja gar nicht mehr zu.
Weil.
Dann müsste ich erst runter schalten.
Und dann.
Und dann müsste ich erst runter schalten.
Auf den kleinsten Gang.
Kein Problem.
Und ich müsste das.
Die Schaltung wieder.
Wieder ein bisschen rausdrehen.
Dass halt die Kette.
Genug Spielraum hat.
Dass ich sie zusammen kriege.
Also.
Was habe ich gemacht.
Faul wie ich war.
Ich habe einfach unten diesen Käfig vom Schaltwerk.
Von Hand nach vorne gedrückt.
So dass die Kette wieder genug Spielraum hat.
Um es zusammenzuklemmen.
Nachdem ich allerdings.
Beide Hände brauche.
Um.
Das Kettenschloss an der Kette.
Das sieht dann so aus.
Zeige ich euch mal.
Ein Bild zum.
So sieht so ein Kettenschloss.
Aus für die Kette.
Nachdem ich beide Hände.
Gebraucht habe.
Um die Kette zu.
Zu machen.
Habe ich.
Einfach.
Mein Knie.
Hinter.
Den.
Käfig von.
Der Schaltung geklemmt.
Sodass dies vorne bleibt.
Da ist schon.
Einiges.
An Spannung.
Darauf.
Ja.
Und irgendwie.
Hatte ich.
Da mein Knie zu fest.
Und zu schräg dran.
Danach war.
Der Kettenschloss.
Käfig verbogen von meiner Schaltung.
Und ich hab mich erst gewundert,
das war auch sehr akrobatisch,
und ich hab mich erst gewundert, warum die
auf einmal nicht mehr
ordentlich schaltet danach.
Ich hab alles ausprobiert,
adjusted und
sonst wieder gesagt, was ist das für ne Scheiße,
Mann, warum geht das nicht?
Ich hab einen halben Nervenzusammenbruch gehabt.
Was ist das für ne Scheiße? Eben ging's doch noch.
Und was soll der Kack?
So, und
naja, was hab ich
gemacht? Ich hab halt
gleich mal
prophylaktisch ne neue Schaltung bestellt.
Ich hätte auch einfach nur nen Käfig bestellen
können, aber ich hab prophylaktisch, weil ich brauch bestimmt
eh nochmal eine, weil irgendwann mal was kaputt geht,
ne neue Schaltung bestellt.
Das ist ne elektronische Schaltung, die kostet halt einfach gleich mal
270 Euro.
Aber man gönnt sich
ja sonst nix.
Die hab ich gestern dran geschraubt
und danach hat wieder alles perfekt geschaltet.
Und heute bin ich ne Runde Probe gefahren
und ich sag euch, ey,
ich hatte ein bisschen Schiss,
weil ich vergessen hab, das Kettenschloss zu wechseln.
Ich hatte das Kettenschloss dran, was ich schon
irgendwie sieben, acht Mal gewechselt hab
und der Hersteller sagt, man darf es nur einmal
verwenden, aber drauf geschissen.
Ich hab immer quasi heute beim Fahren drauf gewartet,
dass die Kette auseinander fällt, aber ist nix passiert.
Ich hab so ein
wiederverstellbares Kettenschloss mir jetzt gekauft,
das ist kein Problem. Zumindest heute bin ich
ne Runde gefahren mit frisch
gewachster
Kette
und ein bisschen größerer
Übersetzung, also einfacheren Gang
für berghoch. Und ich bin die
gleiche Strecke gefahren wie das letzte Mal
und heute hatte ich, ich hab leider meine
Wattmessungspedale noch
nicht dran.
Ich bin die gleiche Strecke gefahren
wie das letzte Mal zum Testen.
Heute war ich ein kmh
schneller als das letzte Mal
und hatte sechs,
ja, knapp sechs Herzschläge
Puls weniger als
das letzte Mal. Also,
scheint zu flutschen, ja.
Oder ich hatte weniger nervige Gassigänger
und Rentner auf der Straße, das kann auch sein.
Man weiß es nicht.
Tätke, was ist hier
eigentlich los?
Ich, ich seh das, ich seh das gerade.
Zu viel, zu viel Fahrradtalk
anscheinend oder Twitch hat's noch nicht gecheckt
oder ist grad irgendwas?
Ist grad irgendwas? Weil normalerweise
dauert's keine zwei Minuten, dann sind's so
130, 140 Leute
und nicht nach einer Viertelstunde 85.
Wahrscheinlich
interessiert alle kein Go-Sätge.
Aber kann man nix machen.
Heute wird Go
gestelzt.
Also, offiziell sagt der Hersteller
des Kettenschlosses, man darf es genau
einmal verwenden.
Aber die sagen wahrscheinlich viel, wenn der Tag lang ist,
einfach um mehr zu verkaufen, ja.
Ich mach doch immer Side-Tracking.
Die erste Viertelstunde.
Lerne C an der
TH und weiß schon alles.
Denkst du?
Oder weißt du? Also, denkst du?
Weißt du, du weißt schon alles oder bist du dir sicher?
Ja, denk ich auch.
Aber ich merk's echt im Bein.
Wir müssen grad noch mal die Idees
updaten. Gucken, ob wir
die letzte
Version Go-Land haben und da erzähl ich euch
auch, was wir in Go basteln.
Leute, ich hab ja letztens
während des hier... Oh nein!
Nein! Nicht wieder der Kack-Bug!
Was ist das denn, Mann?
Die letzten Male ging's doch alles wunderbar.
Ja.
Nicht wieder dieser Bug!
Jetzt crasht es wieder, wenn ich
die Jetbrains-Toolbox aufmache.
Fucking shit, Mann!
Das ist irgendein VMware-Windows-Bug.
Irgendein dummer VMware-Windows-Bug.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das für ein Schrott ist, Mann.
Das ist so...
Alter!
Was ist das denn?
Ich mein, ich weiß,
ich weiß, wie man das fixt.
Man muss VMware abschießen.
Wo ist es denn überhaupt?
Sieht's jemand? Wo ist VMware?
Ja, VMware Workstation. Bam.
Oh, VMware muss man abschießen.
Da muss man VMware neu aufmachen und dann...
Irgendwann geht's.
Oder auch nicht.
Doch, jetzt geht's.
Was für ein Schrott, Alter!
Jetzt hängt's wieder?
Oh, nee.
Oh, Crash-Girl.
VMware will nicht, dass du das in der VMware...
Oh, nee.
Pause-Champ?
Alter, was ist denn jetzt, man?
VMware, please.
Okay.
Prozessor-Explorer öffnen.
Nach CPU sortieren.
VMware, hier.
VMware muss weg.
Okay, ich glaube jetzt...
Ich glaube jetzt...
Ich glaube jetzt geht's wieder...
Brake.
Okay.
Okay, jetzt geht's wieder...
Ah, okay
Ah, man, ey
Hier sind die Gefahren
von C++ für
Minderjährige, okay
Ja, also man sollte auch
man sollte auch mindestens 21 sein
um C++ ertragen
zu können
Also ich verstehe das schon
Du musst die Leute vor sich selbst schützen
Ne, Link ist nicht gefährlich
Das ist Hacker-News
Hacker-News
Chat-GPT gibt ihm keine Antwort auf C++-Fragen
weil er nicht 18 ist, verständlich
Relatable
Leute, ich hab's heute auf Twitter
geschrieben, sorry, auf X
Auf X hab ich es geschrieben
Auf X
Oder wie auch immer man das richtig ausspricht
Ich hab heute jemanden vor mir gehabt, der hatte Schuhe
an mit goldenen Vorhängeschlössern
dran, kein Witz
Und ich dachte mir, das ist irgendein
Jugendtrend
Aber anscheinend ist es das nicht
Ich dachte, das ist vielleicht irgendein Jugendtrend
den ich als Boomer wieder nicht checke
Hätte ja sein können
Aber ist es nicht
Leute, die Toolbox ist im Arsch
Ich mach nix
Ich beweg die Maus nicht
Ich warte
bis es gestartet ist
Okay
Jetzt geh ich hierhin, check update
und guck ob Goland gestartet ist
Und jetzt mach ich ganz schnell wieder zu
nicht, dass es gleich wieder crasht
Okay, wunderbar
Es war kein
Es war
Twitter ist auch schlau
Twitter hat mir gesagt
Das ist eine Schuhmarke, die sich
Buschemischuhe
oder so nennt
Und guckt, die gibt es mit
So was war das in der Richtung
Das waren Schuhe mit Schlössern
mit goldenen Schlössern hinten dran
Wo ich mir gedacht hab, what the fuck
So was in der Richtung
Was das sein soll
Das sind Schuhe mit goldenen Vorhängeschlössern dran
Ich weiß, ich weiß doch auch nicht warum
Aber es sind Schuhe mit goldenen Vorhängeschlössern dran
Guck, sowas in der Richtung hatte der an
Wobei es mehr Turnschuh mäßig aussah, was der anhatte
Sieht arsch teuer aus, naja
Kosten 670 Pfund
Hier 740 Euro
Ja, wer goldene Vorhängeschlösser will
die 2,50 Euro bei den China-Chinesen kosten
Der muss schon nach 600, 700 Euro
latzen
Dafür krieg ich 3 extra weite
Ich brauch ja extra weite Schuhe
Hab ich euch ja schon mal erzählt
Weil ich so fette
Äh, fett sind die gar nicht
Mal breit sind die halt
Füße hab
Brauch ich, ich brauch extra, extra breite Schuhe
Und die sind auch teuer as fuck
Aber davon krieg ich, davon krieg ich
3 reichen ja, davon krieg ich
Für den Preis von denen krieg ich
Krieg ich ja eigentlich fast schon 4
Ja
Naja, also ich erzähl euch mal
Ich erzähl euch mal was wir in Go machen werden
Wir müssen heute mal ein bisschen was ausprobieren
Und zwar
Also
Auf der Arbeit
Ich hab euch schon ein paar mal erzählt
Ich bin dort unter anderem in einem Projekt
Wo es um Block-Chain-Technologie geht
Eigentlich ist das schon wieder outdated, overrated, jebaited
Aber ihr könnt euch überlegen, wenn
Jetzt gerade Versicherungen und Banken
Und die Finanzbranche, so die richtigen
Allschool-Finanzunternehmen
Damit anfangen
Die fangen immer erst mit sowas an
Wenn der Hype eigentlich schon vorbei ist
Doomsweb, danke schon für den Sub
Heißt im Endeffekt
Die sind da immer ein bisschen hinten dran
Deswegen machen wir jetzt auch Cag-Business-Block-Chain
So
Wir betreiben einige
Blockchain-Nodes
Nennt sich das
Selber
Unter anderem betreiben wir
Polygon-Block-Chain-Nodes
Das ist ja so ein Beispiel, wir haben noch mehr
Aber Polygon ist
Glaube ich mit das bekannteste
Von dem was wir betreiben
Und
Das Ding ist
Das das Monitoring oder die Überwachung
Von diesen Polygon
Containern
Ziemlich
Suboptimal ist
Also die hängen öfters mal
Wegen irgendwelchen Sachen
Das sind wir nicht die einzigen, die Probleme haben
Und man bekommt es nicht richtig mit
Aber
Man kann die über eine API abfragen
Was ist denn dein letzter Block
Den du gesehen hast
Und dann kann man noch eine zweite Abfrage machen
Sag mir mal den Timestamp
Vom aktuellen Block
Und dann kannst du den
Aktuellen Timestamp nehmen
Minus aktuelle Uhrzeit
Und dann weißt du wie alt dein Block ist
Das dumme ist nur
Das diese Metriken
Oder diese Infos
Die musst du dir selbst zusammenbauen
Das bietet die Software die wir verwenden
Dafür nicht an
Unsere Software bietet nur die Info an
Was letzter Block
Deswegen
Habe ich vorgeschlagen
Wisst ihr was
Wir bauen einfach
Wir betreiben das ganze im Kubernetes Cluster
Wir machen heute nichts mit Kubernetes
Wir machen heute wirklich ein bisschen Go gebastelt
Deswegen habe ich gesagt wisst ihr was
Was haltet ihr denn davon
Wenn wir neben den ganzen Blockchain Sachen
Noch einen
eigenen Pod bauen
Also einen eigenen Container bauen
Und den mit deployen ins Kubernetes
Der diese Metriken bereitstellt
In Kubernetes
Fachkreis nennt man sowas
Sidecar Container
Also man packt quasi noch
Einen weiteren Container
In das Deployment dabei
Der dann nur Metriken bereitstellt
Und wie stellt man am besten
Metriken bereit Chat
Cloud Native Hyper Agile
Mit was macht man das
Was ist da angesagt
Wer weiß es
Vor allem wo hat Google eine gute Unterstützung für
Ich pause
Champ jetzt so lange bis irgend einer
Irgendwas sagt auch wenn es falsch ist
Prometheus richtig
Ja Gott sei Dank
Ich habe gerade echt überlegt was mache ich denn
Was mache ich denn wenn jetzt keiner was sagt
Prometheus
Korrekt
Zumal Google auch schon Managed Prometheus anbietet
Und das haben wir
Testweise in Benutzung deswegen
Möchte ich in Go
Einen Prometheus Exporter bauen
Der die API abfragt
Von Polygon
Und Metriken
Zurück liefert nämlich
Letzter Block
Datum
Und ja
Zeit
Vergangen
Zeit letzter Block
Du willst dein Timeout haben
Ähm
Sorry for Bash
Dankeschön für den Sub
Excellent
Sehr sehr nice
Und deswegen
Ja
Habe ich letztens bin ich
Tufälligerweise drüber gestolpert
Ist das die Programmiersprache die so einen komischen
Komischen Pipe Operator
Hat wo ich
Wo ich gesagt habe
Der ist der sieht super hässlich aus
Ja ist das so
Okay
Ich
Untime oute euch mal
Wieder
Magst du an String erinnern sehr gute Einwand
Excellent
Ja
Ist das nicht irgendwas in Erlang
Gleam
Oder wie das heißt
War das nicht auf Erlang Basis
Okay Chat
Bevor wir anfangen hat man verstanden
Was ich machen will
Also im Endeffekt will ich
Mit dem Metaverse Exporter bauen
Der Custommetriken von uns abfragt
Und dann
Ja dann bauen wir ein Docker Image
Damit drin wobei ganz ehrlich weiß ich ob ich das heute mache
Also Custommetrikexporter
In Go
Ich habe das mir vor
Uhrzeiten schon mal angeguckt
Also in .net habe ich es schon oft gemacht
In Go habe ich mir das vor Uhrzeiten mal angeguckt
Habe aber vergessen wie es funktioniert
Das heißt da müssen wir uns jetzt mal
Irgendwas raussuchen
Open Telemetry
Oder Golang
Prometheus
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher nach was man da gescheit suchen muss
Ja also folgender Plan
Folgender Plan
Wir haben ein Deployment
Ein Kubernetes Deployment
Da ist das ganze Blockchain Zeug drin
Da sind aktuell zwei Container in einem Pott
Und da kommt jetzt noch ein dritter Sidecar Container
Dabei
Der die Metriken bereitstellt
Der macht ein paar API Abrufe
Gegen Local Hoster
Also quasi im gleichen IP Bereich drinnen
Der macht dann ein paar API Abfragen gegen Local Host
Gegen den eigentlichen Blockchain Node
Und
Daraus generiert er dann drei vier Metriken
Je nachdem was wir alles brauchen
Und stellt das bereit
So das Prometheus das ganze crawlen kann
So machen wir das
Was nutzt ihr für die Visualisierung der Metriken Grafana
Ja auch
Das Ding ist
Wie gesagt ich arbeite ja bei einer Versicherung
Das ist so nervig
Was dort an Netzwerk Restriktionen ist
Das ist immer alles ein riesen Akt
Bis irgendwo was funktioniert
Das heißt wir verwenden Grafana
Dort wo es geht
Und dort wo es noch ewig dauert
Bis alles freigeschaltet ist
Verwenden wir so lange das Google Cloud
Also die Dashboards die man in Google Cloud erstellen kann
Ich finde das extrem hakelig
Lahm und nervig die Google Cloud Dashboards
Das ist wirklich so ein Grafana
Very light
Aber bis Grafana dahin kommt und alles Collected ist
Kann erstmal damit
Ja
Das finde ich sehr nice
Vielleicht wirst du ja irgendwann auch mal zum IT Guy
Weil der Quereinstieg ist aktuell
So gut wie noch nie möglich
Und außerdem werden händeringend Leute gesucht
Und man kann auch noch eine Ausbildung machen
Wenn man 30 plus ist
Gar kein Problem
So also das ist das was wir heute vorhaben
Ich starte mal kurz meine Go-Idee
Ja
Ich musste auch letztens wieder
Ich hab letztens den Fehler gemacht
Wo sind wir denn hier stehen geblieben
MonkaS
Das ist ja AI Assistant
Nein nein nein
Geh mal weg
So
Ja das ist nochmal
New
Wir machen mal kurz
Neues Verzeichnis
Repos
Mkdir
Wie nennen wir das Ding
Krypto
Ode
Block
Block Chain
Monitor Champ
Irgendwie so
So nennen wir das
Goland
Punkt
Naja wir trusten dem Project
Gar kein Problem
Das ist gar kein Project
Wait a minute
Ich bin immer wenn ich lange nichts in Go gemacht habe
Bin ich immer verwirrt wie das funktioniert
Wartet mal
Mein Mustardman sagt New
Project
So und jetzt
Blockchain nicht Black
Blockchain
Monitor Champ
Da wollen wir hin
Und ist das jetzt
Ist das jetzt standardmäßig ein Go Modules Projekt
Ich glaube schon
By the way ich checke nicht was das hier macht
Was macht das?
Äh
Was
Das ist überhaupt kein Projekt drinne
Alter
Muss ich verarschen
Da ist doch überhaupt nichts drinne alter
Was ist das hier
Oder
Was drinne
Ach da ist der IDE Ordner drinne
Alter
Pepega Jetbrains
Wie erhebst du eigentlich Metriken
Ja also für den
Das funktioniert jetzt please
Jetzt hat er das wieder geöffnet
Ich muss das schon wieder löschen
Ähm
In dem Fall
Mache ich paar Abfragen
Gegen die AP von dem eigentlichen Service
Rechne ein bisschen was mit dem Datum aus
Und
Dann exportiere ich das als
Prometheus Metriken
Das Window
Ok jetzt hat er das gecheckt
Ok das ist auch
Ein Go
Modules Projekt
Ok sehr schön
Also welcher Service
Ach so was wir da verwenden
Das kann ich tatsächlich zeigen
Weil das ist ein Open Source Projekt
Wir verwenden da
Das da
Das ist eine
Ethereum Implementierung
Aber das kann ganz viele verschiedene Blockchains
Unter anderem Polygon
Coq steht ja auch hier
Polygon
Coq Knossi kann das auch
Und das Ding bietet eine AP an
Und die AP werde ich abfragen
Ich hole mir raus
Letzter Block
Ich mach mal kurz hier
Go file main.go
Ja
Also ich muss mir dann rausholen
Warte mal wie war das in Go so
Was letzter Block
Letzter Block
Ähm
ID oder so
Wobei das haben wir ja schon
Block ID
Letzter Block Datum
Oder Timestamp
Timestamp
Und
Letzter Block
Ja
Ähm
Nicht Timestamp
Zeit
Oder wie alt
Also quasi aktuelle Zeit
Minus die Zeit
Von hier
Das sind die drei Metriken
Und ich muss jetzt gucken
Wie man in Go einen eigenen
Prometheus Exporter baut
Hat jemand schon sowas gemacht
Also ich vermute mal das Open Telemetry
Und irgendwelche Prometheus
Libraries da gute Anlaufpunkte sind
Übrigens
Go init und gut
Macht das dann auch mittlerweile standardmäßig ein Modules Projekt
Und nervt nicht mehr rum mit Go Path
Welche IDE
Ist das
Das ist Go Land
Jetbrains Go Land
Was auch immer
Find ich nice
Es tun auch andere IDE's
Ja du kannst auch
Visual Studio Code nehmen mit dem Go Plugin
Oder manche
Manche Verrückten benutzen auch NeoWim
Das Ding ist ich hab das
All IDE Package
Das heißt ich wär blöd wenn ich es nicht verwende
Und die Dinger taugen von denen auch
Ich benutze nicht alles von denen
Also ich benutze
Also die haben ja hier, guck mal hier
1000 Dinger
Die haben was für Ruby
Hier guck mal die haben
All IDE's
Die haben IntelliJ
IntelliJ kennt wahrscheinlich
Das kennen die wahrscheinlich die meisten
Das ist für die ganzen Java Enjoyer unter uns
Es gibt glaube ich auch IntelliJ Premium
Oder sowas in der Richtung
Kann das sein
Oder ist das nur für Visual Studio
Also IntelliJ
Für die ganzen Java Enjoyer
PyCharm
Wer es braucht
GoLand, Rider, C-Line, RubyMine
Habe ich früher ab und zu mal verwendet
Rust Rover haben wir auch schon benutzt
Also von den IDE's von denen verwende ich
PyCharm ab und zu mal
Du hast bestimmt 10 JetBrains IDE's
Ja es ist ein bisschen blöd
Das es nicht so ein Universal Ding gibt
Das stimmt schon
Ich meine mit Fleet wollen sie ja aber ich sehe es aktuell noch nicht
Die brauchen halt auch RAM as fuck
Und Speicher aber hauptsächlich RAM
Also ich verwende von denen ab und zu mal PyCharm
PyCharm gibt es auch in irgendeiner Professional Variante
Ich habe bis heute nicht gecheckt
Was der Unterschied zwischen der Freien und der Professional Variante ist
Ich verwende das ab und zu relativ selten
Das verwende ich häufiger
Das verwende ich sehr oft
Das verwende ich auch ab und zu
Selten
Weil ich selten was in Rust mache
Aber das haben wir auch schon ausprobiert
RubyMine so gut wie gar nicht mehr
Habe ich früher öfters verwendet
Und das war es
Deswegen habe ich mir auch das All Desktop Package gekauft
Und das Zeug taugt echt
Also ich mag die Chat Brand Sachen
Obwohl
Obwohl das auf Java Basis ist
Alles
Also ich programmiere quasi
Go jetzt mit der Hilfe von
Java
Wie das die coolen Leute sagen
Hier gibt es einen Vergleich
Oh
Es gibt vor allem Blendgranate
Was
Kann das mal please
Meine Augen man
Also
Ja gut die ganzen Languages jucken mich null
Das ist auch
Dafür bin
Also ganz ehrlich für Frontend bin ich auf
Visual Studio Code hängen geblieben
Ich könnte natürlich auch
Webstorm verwenden mache ich aber nicht
Für Frontend verwende ich tatsächlich
Was anderes
Als Chat Brand Sachen
Also ich sehe da keinen großen Vorteil
Ich meine Perforce
Oder Perforce ich weiß gar nicht wie man das ausspricht
Benutzt das überhaupt irgendjemand?
Wie sieht dein PS1 im Terminal aus?
Was?
Starcraft ich weiß legit nicht was du meinst
Ist PS1 PowerShell?
Ich benutze keine PowerShell das ist Linux
Das ist ZSH
Nicht PowerShell
Da würde ich ja
Krämpfe bekommen wenn ich PowerShell benutzen muss hier
Das stimmt die schnellsten IDEs sind das nicht
Aber wenn die Sachen erstmal geladen sind voll und voll
Ok
Das ist gar nicht so schlimm
Doch ich finde PowerShell ist schlimm
Als interaktive Shell finde ich PowerShell ganz grausam
Also ich meine
Alles ist besser als Batch
Hat jemand mal die Ehre mit Windows
Also alles
Ich weiß gar nicht wie die Standard Shell heißt von Windows
Die man mit CMD aufmacht
Heißt die auch CMD heißt die Batch
Batch ist die Skripting Sprache
Das ist natürlich super extrem
Also
Die größte Scheiße die es gibt
PowerShell ist ganz ok
Im Vergleich dazu
Aber PowerShell finde ich ist keine gute
Interaktive Shell
PowerShell ist dafür extrem nice zum automatisieren
Für Windows Sachen
Übrigens Leute
Microsoft hat wieder zugeschlagen
Wusstet ihr
Wusstet ihr das
Microsoft Office
Für Server
Deprecated ist
Ok findet man gar nicht in den News
Supported offiziell bald nicht mehr
Office auf Servern
Fragt mich nicht warum es Leute gibt
Die Microsoft Office auf Servern installiert haben
Aber das wird nicht mehr supported
Von Microsoft
Ach das meinst du
Du meinst dein Command Prompt
Ok
Jetzt habe ich es verstanden
Der sieht
Nicht so aus
Wie du dir das vorstellst
Ich benutze Starship
Starship generiert das on the fly
Dynamisch
Und das passiert hier drinnen
Da
Starship
Starship setzt den Prompt quasi
Wenn man das hier ausführt
Dann siehst du hier guck
Was Starship macht
Will man aber nicht
Die Shell ist
Quasi wird dynamisch generiert
Von Starship
Und Starship ist natürlich der beste Prompt
Weil
Ihr seht es schon an der Domain
Blazingly Fast
Written in Rust
Das kann auch was taugen
Ich habe ein bisschen was Customized da dran
Wenn du genau wissen willst
Was ich Customized habe
Kannst du hier in meine Dot Files gucken
Da ist was drin
Dot Config
Starship
Hier siehst du die Config für mein Prompt
Ich habe eigentlich nur das Default Theme
Ein bisschen angepasst
Oder eines der mitgelieferten Themes
Ein bisschen besser lesbar gemacht
Und
Ich glaube noch ein paar Infos hinzugefügt
Für C Sharp Projekte
Für Dot Net Projekte
Und das war es
Mehr habe ich nicht gemacht
Kennst du das von Arch?
Ich use auch Arch
Ich dachte mir ich erwähne das mal
Weil alle coolen Leute Arch verwenden
By the way
Was ist mit Terminal Server
Tja weiß ich nicht
Da ist es wahrscheinlich noch ok
Habe ich heute gehört auf der Arbeit
Microsoft supportet kein Office mehr
Auf Windows Server
Das erste was ich mir gedacht habe ist
Was es gibt wirklich paar Verrückte
Die nicht nur Windows Server einsetzen
Sondern auch wirklich Office da drauf installiert haben
Denkt ihr Programmierkenntnisse werden
Künftig mehr oder weniger
Nein Quatsch
Das glaube ich nicht
Es gab schon so ein paar Trends
Eines der letzten Trends war diese ganze Low Code No Code Geschichte
Die im Endeffekt eigentlich noch dazu führt
Dass du eher noch mehr brauchst
An Entwicklern
Die das quasi dann so bauen
Das Noobs es wieder können
Ich halte übrigens von den meisten
No Code Low Code Sachen überhaupt gar nichts
Und
Ich glaube auch nicht
Dass uns Machine Learning irgendwie
Ersetzen wird
Es wird auf jeden Fall als Unterstützung
Wichtiger werden
Aber du wirst keine Programmierer ersetzen
Mit Machine Learning
Ich glaube sogar eher
Das weil viele mehr auf KI aufspringen
Ist es natürlich nicht verkehrt
Sich ein bisschen damit auszukennen
Und ich gehe davon aus dass ich sogar kurzfristig
Eher mehr Leute suchen werden
Weil der Bereich noch dazu gekommen ist
Ja Sadge Sadge
Schlimm oder
Ich kann beruflich kein Windows äh
Das wäre schön
Ich kann beruflich kein Linux verwenden
Also das stimmt nicht
Ich verdiene mit Linux auch beruflich mein Geld
Aber auf meinem Notebook
Also auf meinen
Quasi meiner Workstation
Kann ich kein Linux verwenden
Weil da muss ich das offizielle
Image von der Firma verwenden
Wo erstmal 75 Security Tools laufen
Und das ist so schlimm
Das ist ein richtig fetter Laptop
Irgendwie 8 Kerne 32 GB
Aber der ist echt so krass langsam
Durch dieses ganze Security Zeug
Da drehst du echt ab
Schlimm
Übrigens ich muss gerade auch mal was los fangen Leute
Twitter hat mich wieder echt super
Verwirrt die letzten Tage ne
Ich darf noch ein bisschen Zeit getrackt werden
Weil die Stunde ist noch nicht um
Es fällt mir gerade so ein
Twitter hat mich wieder echt mal wieder
Ich hab
Die letzten Tage auf Twitter wieder realisiert
Warum
Meine Heimat auf Twitter Andorra ist
Da muss man sich nämlich die Deutschen
Beziehungsweise so die
Ganzen größeren internationalen Trends
Nicht angucken in Andorra kommt das nicht an
Die einzigen Sachen die in Andorra trenden
Sind ab und zu mal
Andorra selbst
Wo ich nicht genau weiß warum
Und manchmal trendet Tour de France
Wenn die nach Andorra fährt
Ansonsten trendet auf Twitter in Andorra
Legit nichts
Ich habe keine Trends in Andorra
Was sehr gut ist
Twitter Trends gerade die Deutschen
Ey du flippst aus im Kopf
Letztens
Hab ich gesehen
Hat getrendet Blutbad
Und da hab ich mir erst mal gedacht Alter
Irgendjemand Amok gelaufen wieder
Was ist gewesen
Und dann kommt raus
Trump hat irgendeine komische
Pepega Rede gehalten
Und alle haben sich super krass reingesteigert wieder
Und sind da eskaliert auf Twitter
Alter
Wo ich immer denke haben die alles sonst überhaupt
Gar keine Probleme mehr
Ist denen ihre Zeit echt nicht zu schade dafür
Aber anscheinend nicht
Die haben sich so krass reingesteigert wieder
Ich hab mir den Clip
Angeguckt
Und hab mir gedacht okay
Ich mein
Ist halt bisschen scharfe Rhetorik
So what
Hat mich so null tangiert
Er hat schon so viel komisches Zeug erzählt
Ja okay so what next
Du steigerst dich in Twitch rein
Auf Twitch rein steigern finde ich auch nice
Aber auf Twitter verstehe ich das nicht
Es war super aus
Ja du hast recht
Es war super aus dem Kontext gerissen
Was auch so ein Ding
Gegenbeispiel ja
Welche Seite es gibt ja nicht nur zwei Seiten
Es gibt ja gefühlt unendlich viele
Seiten
Auf Twitter
Die sich gerne die Köppe einschlagen
Es ist letztens auch in Deutschland
Es war ein deutscher Trend auf Twitter
Ratten ist getrendet
Da hat unser Bundespräsident in irgendeiner Rede erzählt
Irgendwas von Rattenfängern
Der hat nicht gesagt das die Wähler Ratten sind
Und da kam dann die
Die ganzen Verschwörungstheorie Leuten
Und rechten Leute kamen dann an
Und der Bundespräsident bezeichnet alle als Ratten
Ich hab mir den Ausschnitt angeguckt
Denkt mir so
Alter ihr glaubt auch das Zitronenfalter
Zitronenfalten oder
Wenn man das wörtlich nimmt
Das hat er überhaupt nicht gesagt
Ja klar
Der hat die
Als Rattenfänger bezeichnet
Aber damit ist noch eindeutig gemeint
So nach dem Motto
Genau das hat er gesagt
Damit ist noch eindeutig gemeint
Also was er sagen möchte ist
Die labert viel wenn der Tag lang ist
Auf gut Deutsch
Wie man dort auf die Idee kommen kann
Das wörtlich zu nehmen verstehe ich nicht
Ich mein Chat Chat
Wenn der Chat mal wieder so richtig
Pepega Chatting betreibt
Und ich sag Chat ihr seid aber heute ganz schön hirnlos
Was ich nicht sage
Weil mein Chat ist natürlich high IQ und schlau
Und durch jeden Sub steigt der Durchschnitts IQ
Am Angenommen ich sage Chat ihr seid ja heute wieder ganz schön hirnlos
Damit meine ich doch nicht wörtlich
Dass ihr heute ganz schön hirnlos seid
Weil ihr in eurem Schädel keine Gehirnmasse habt
Ich mein damit
Ihr seid heute ganz schön blöd
Bei manchen bin ich mir da nicht so sicher
Bei manchen kann das schon sein
Gerade auf Twitter
Und da hab ich mir gedacht
Alter wie kann man das wörtlich nehmen
Und gestern oder so wann das war
Als ich diesen Trend gelesen hab mit Blutbad zu Trump
Erste was ich bei sowas mache ist
Immer ich guck mir mal den Clip an
Guck ich mir den Clip an
Und denk mir danach so
Ja so what
Er hat ja eigentlich gar nichts wildes gesagt
Er hat Sinn
Also für alle die den Clip nicht gesehen hat
Für alle die den Clip nicht gesehen haben
Er hat sinngemäß gesagt
Also er hat das Wort Blutbad ist gefallen
Aber in einem komplett anderen Kontext
Der hat sinngemäß gesagt
Die Chinesen oder ich glaub die Chinesen waren es
Die Chinesen wären ja in Mexiko
Und äh
Der wird dafür sorgen
Dass die da keinen Fuß fassen können
Die Chinesen in Mexiko
Wird das alles super krass besteuert
Und ähm
Wenn
Wenn er gewählt wird
Oder nur wenn er gewählt wird
Bringt er das in Ordnung
Dass die Chinesen da in Mexiko
Hier nicht irgendwie ihre Dinger treiben können
Aber wenn er nicht gewählt wird
Dann gibt das ein Blutbad
So das hat er gesagt
Wie man da wortwörtlich drauf kommen kann
Dass es ein Blutbad im wörtlichen Sinne gibt
Ey keine Ahnung
Ich versteh nicht
Was mit den Leuten los ist
Du musst dir einfach nur 1 Minute 30 Clip angucken
Und du weißt sofort ey
Nix dran
Und ich bin schon
Ich bin schon gespannt
Was da noch kommt
Ich mein dass der Kerl öfters mal Blödsinn erzählt
Ich sag bloß
Desinfektionsmittel trinken bei Corona
Und sowas
Ne müssen wir nicht von reden
In dem Fall war halt nichts
Irgendwie im wörtlichen Sinne
Da rein zu interpretieren
Konnte ich die ganze Aufregung
Wiederhaut nicht verstehen
Und das waren jetzt 2 Beispiele
Die mir so spontan eingefallen sind
So mit den Ratten und dem Blutbad
Wo man wieder sieht
Da wird sich einfach nur 1 Wort rausgepickt
Was ohne Kontext
Einfach nur halt heftig so klingt
Aber was wenn du dir das beim näher betrachtest
So gar nix wildes dran ist
Oh ne
Wir flippen immer aus
Und ich denk mir dann immer so
Irgendwie in eurem Leben anderes zu tun
Wo ihr euch Sorgen drüber machen müsst
Ey keine Ahnung
Ist egal
Genug Zeit getrackt
Das programmieren wir go
Ich versteh die Welt dann teilweise echt nicht
So
Jetzt wird go geproggert
Also
Wir wollen
Wir machen einen Prometheus Exporter
Hab ich noch nie gemacht
Wie macht man einen Prometheus Exporter
Hab ich schon mal mir vor Jahren angeguckt
So
Chat wie würdet ihr
Wirklich ist so Twitter hältst du nicht länger aus
Chat wie würdet ihr heute
Einen Prometheus Exporter machen in go
Mit irgendwelchen OpenTelemetry
Lips
Oder mit einer dedizierten
Prometheus Library
OpenTelemetry ist ja
Würde ich sagen prinzipiell eher sinnvoll
Wenn man ne Anwendung hat
Und daraus Metriken exportieren will
Und vielleicht nicht nur Metriken für Prometheus
Sondern auch
Logs oder in einem anderen Format
Und sowas
Ja ne mit Standard Lips kannst du schon mal vergessen
Ja
Wie macht man denn einen Prometheus
Prometheus Prometheus
Library for go
Nice
Exemplars
Ist ihm noch nicht aufgefallen
In den letzten
Zwei Jahren
Das sein Ordner falsch heißt
Simpel
Simpel klingt gut
Simpel finde ich nice
Ok
Also was brauchen wir
Klein
Golang
Prometheus Prometheus
Prom http
Flag String Listen
Was
Registry
Collectors
What
letting
The
Dotnet
Prometer
Library
Ist schon n bisschen
Pepega zu bedienen
Aber was bin ich denn hier sehend
Und wir gucken uns mal
Wir gucken uns mal kurz n OpenTelemetry Beispiel an
Ok
Examples
Promise
Oder wie die Amis sagen
Mit dem ich in Discord geschwätzt habe, hat nicht DHL gesagt, das ist ein Deutscher, ja, genau, der hat nicht DHL gesagt, der hat ernsthaft gesagt, bei DHL, da muss ich erstmal kurz überlegen, meint der jetzt DHL oder meint der jetzt was anderes, was zufälligerweise genauso abgekürzt wird, aber nein, der meint wirklich DHL.
Also, DHL ist doch richtig, warum ist das richtig? Und wenn du mir jetzt kommst mit, dass das eigentlich eine, frag mich nicht, eine US-Firma, ich weiß es gar nicht, wo die gegründet wurde, ja, hast du recht, ist aber vollkommen irrelevant in dem Fall, wir haben uns hier drauf geeinigt, dass es DHL heißt, jeder sagt DHL und DHL selber sagt in Deutschland DHL.
Übrigens, Amazon hat auch DHL.
Amazon hat auch in ihrer Werbung früher gesagt, Amazon. Mittlerweile sind sie auch schon bei, bei Emerson. Aber es kommt, und außerdem, und außerdem ist Emerson, hört sich irgendwie noch ganz okay an, aber DHL, wir können nur froh sein, dass kein W in DHL ist, stellt euch mal vor, das würde, keine Ahnung, DWL oder so heißen, dann würde es DWL heißen, noch schlimmer, man muss ja, also, ganz ehrlich, W ist kein W.
WTF ist, glaube ich, der, der größte Pepega-Buchstabe, den es gibt. Die, die, die Amis, ja, also, wir sagen, HTTP, also, wir sagen, www.google.de und die Amis müssen wirklich sagen, www.google.de, also, das ist so hängen geblieben, da fällt mir echt nichts mehr zu ein, deswegen ignoriere ich jegliche Abkürzung mit W drin, ne.
Ja, WTF ist auch sowas.
Auszusprechen, ja, aber WTF, ne, oh, guck mal, es gibt Documentation, ah, das sind, Leute, das ist mein Mann, der das hier erstellt hat.
Es gibt keine Dokumentation, der ist Wubbler-Certified, der weiß, wie es geht, es funktioniert einfach.
Der Code dokumentiert sich selbst.
Ja, das werden wir jetzt mal überprüfen, inwieweit sich der Code selbst dokumentiert.
Zeigt mal her, wie, wie, wie selbst dokumentiert sich?
Der Code, Const Meta Name, ich hab ernsthaft keine Ahnung, was diese Syntax in Go bedeutet.
Const Meta Name und dann ein Link zu GitHub, what?
Was ist das?
Ist das sowas wie ein Export, ein Rename von einem Export in JavaScript?
Dass man nicht will, dass das Ganze irgendwie konfliktet?
Ne, Moment, Examples?
Ich, okay, absolut kein Plastenschiff.
Ich weiß nicht immer, was, was die wollen, was das bedeuten soll.
New Source, New Meta Provider, boah, das ist ja ne Wissen, Alter, what the fuck?
Das ist ja ne Wissenschaft für sich.
Meta.float64ObservableGauch, okay, das kommt mir ein bisschen, also, mal ganz im Ernst,
die, die .NET Library ist schon nicht schön.
Für Prometheus, ja?
Und die Beispiele sind noch beschissener.
Ja, aber die sieht, die sieht besser aus als das.
Wo kommt Meta her?
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich hier.
Okay, Moment, wir brauchen mal, wir brauchen hier, wir nehmen mal das.
Also, wie, wie funsten das Ganze?
Gibt es vielleicht auch eine nicht-simple-Exporter, Exemplars, nehmen wir jetzt mal.
Main Go.
Okay, hier ist ein bisschen mehr drin, ne?
Also, Requestorations, New Histogram, Create Registry, Add Go Runtime Matrix and Provide Collectors.
Nee, Go Runtime Matrix können wir exportieren, why not?
Schadet nix.
Kostet Geld, wenn man es bei Google speichert.
Das ist quasi eine Endlosschleife mit einem Sleep, die die Werte updatet.
Okay, das check ich.
Ist doch, okay, ich nehme das zurück.
Ist doch halbwegs.
Simpel, oder?
Glaub mir, versteht man, probieren wir nochmal.
Also, dann importieren wir mal das Ganze.
Nee, Moment, Package darf nicht so heißen.
Package muss Main heißen, sonst funzt es ja nicht.
Was, sind die Mikroner dahinter?
Nee.
Was ist das für ein Problem jetzt?
Ach, Moment, da muss Import davor.
Ich kack Noob.
Import.
Lul.
Alles, hopp.
Ey, warum, warum ist das weg?
Ach so, weil Go, weil Go wieder am Nerven ist.
Go ist wieder am Nerven, weil ich die Dinger nirgendswo verwende.
Ja, ja, ja, okay.
Das sind so kleine Dinger, die mich übelst abfacken.
Nee, wahrscheinlich muss ich die nicht manuell importieren.
Mach ich aber gerne, weil ich dann direkt Autocomplete hab.
Okay, mit Prometheus kann man irgendwas an...
Jetzt ist er schon wieder weg.
Bleibst du mal da?
Es downloadet übrigens noch.
Du musst nur Go get link, dann macht er das selber.
Ja.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was der dann selber macht, auf was sich das jetzt bezieht.
Du kannst einfach Go Mod Tidy machen und was passiert dann?
Die Imports macht er dann selber.
Wie jetzt?
Äh, vor allem...
Warum?
Ist der jetzt fertig, oder?
Unused Import, okay.
Warum erkennt er jetzt nicht?
Konnte man nicht irgendwie sowas davor machen, dass er es dann ignoriert?
Das ist auch...
Das ist auch so ein Go-Magic-Ding, ey.
Sollte ich nicht so...
Ach, Moment, ich brauch Function Main.
Function Main.
Und jetzt kann ich das machen.
Pro Prometheus, da ist es.
So.
Wie geht es jetzt?
Prometheus New.
Prometheus...
Äh...
New?
Counter.
Counter ist schon mal okay, ja.
So, Hilfe.
Hilfe-Texte sind overrated, outdated, jebaited.
Ja.
Dann werden die Imports gedownloadet.
Hat er doch schon gemacht, gerade.
Ja, aber ich will ja Autocomplete haben.
Also, so scheint das ja schon mal zu funzen.
Wir müssen übrigens mal ein Terminal aufmachen.
Machen wir das ohne.
Machen wir das rechts.
Ich mach das hier hin.
Chatgear, ich weiß, es kann sein, ihr müsst mich dran erinnern,
wenn ihr jetzt gleich nichts sehen solltet,
weil manchmal backt das ja immer ein bisschen rum hier unten mit dem Chat.
Ein bisschen breiter, das machen wir weg.
Wir machen das so, dass ich...
Oh, bin mir gar nicht sicher.
Moment.
Ähm, wie kriege ich denn das jetzt gescheit angeordnet?
Meine I3-Skills failen.
Wie kriege ich das gescheit gesplittet auf der rechten Seite jetzt?
Gar nicht.
Ich bilde mir eigentlich ein, dass ich das so machen müsste,
aber das funzt nicht.
Egal.
Dann machen wir einfach so.
Keck, wait.
Repo, splot...
So.
Go, run.
Nee, nicht gotrun.
Go, go, run.
Ich kann nicht schreiben.
Go, run.
So, Punkt.
Oh je.
Ja.
Es hat funktioniert.
Okay, er kackt schon mal nicht komplett ab.
Also, wie funktioniert...
Was macht der Typ jetzt?
Registry.
Create non-global registry.
Okay, whatever.
Keine Ahnung, wofür es gut ist, aber machen wir mal.
Registry must register.
Ich copy-paste mir einfach mal das Beispiel.
Collect your new...
Go, collect your new process...
Alter.
Okay, es...
New process collector returns a collector which exports the current state of process metrics
including CPU, memory and file descriptor usage as well as process start time.
Alles klar.
Das heißt, jetzt habe ich die basic metrics.
Hier, gucken wir uns das doch mal an, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Und jetzt brauchen wir hier Handle.
Ja.
Okay, nice.
Einfach rein, copy, paste und hoffen, dass es funzt.
Ja.
Einfach so einen Curl machen, oder?
Man braucht nicht Open Metrics Text da reinschreiben.
Okay, go, run.
Alles klar.
So, das heißt, wir sollten jetzt eigentlich lokal auf Port 8080 was laufen haben.
Curl, local host, Port 8080, slash geht nicht, slash metrics.
Da ist es doch.
Nice.
Okay, wir haben schon ein paar Standardmetriken exportiert, die keine Sau je auswerten wird.
Aber ich wollte einfach...
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Ne, Leute, ich exportiere die Standardmetriken nicht.
Wobei...
Chat, was meint ihr?
Soll ich die Standardmetriken exportieren oder nicht?
Mein Gedanke ist ja erstmal, eigentlich braucht diese Standardmetriken niemand.
Aber, aber, pass mal auf, aber...
Stellt euch mal vor, wir lassen das jetzt in einem Container laufen.
Und wir geben dem Container, weil das ja quasi nur so ein minimalen Hilfscontainer ist für Metriken,
denen gebe ich irgendwie eine 16. CPU in Kubernetes und 64 MB RAM.
Und wir haben irgendwann mal Probleme und die Metriken werden nicht richtig collected.
So könnte ich tatsächlich sehen, dass mein Prozess immer mal wieder an die Speichergrenze kommt
oder irgendwelche Probleme hat.
Anderweitig nicht.
Was exportiert er denn?
Was ist das?
Enable Open Metrics.
Okay.
Dann machen wir mal das hier kurz weg und gucken mal, was er dann alles exportiert.
Das ist aber...
Das müllt, ganz ehrlich, das müllt eigentlich nur unnötig den Export voll.
Ich glaube, ich lasse das weg.
Scheiße.
Mal gucken.
Ja, jetzt...
Jetzt respondet er halt mit einer leeren Seite.
Genau.
Okay, und wie kriege ich da jetzt Metriken rein?
Ich mach mal kurz die Schriften ein Ticken kleiner.
So, wie kriege ich da jetzt Metriken rein?
Was mit R kannst du Auto reloaden und Change sparst dir dann jedes Mal Go-Run?
Das ist cool, dass sowas wie .NET Watch...
Wie heißt das?
R.
R-Go-Lang.
R?
Live Reload for Go-Apps.
Tatsächlich.
14,7.000 Sterne.
Krass.
Live Reload for Go-Apps.
Wie funktioniert das jetzt?
Ach, das macht im Endeffekt einfach nur ein Watch drauf.
Was ist Goblin Run schon wieder?
Die haben echt alle ein bisschen den Arsch offen, ey.
Go-Lang Binaries in a Curl, Build by Goblins.
Alles klar.
Weißt sofort, was das Projekt macht, oder?
Wir curlen random irgendwelche Sachen aus dem Internet und pipen sie in eine Shell.
Das ist eindeutig der Weg.
Go-Install.
Ich geh mal davon aus, ich hab die Sachen gar nicht in meinem Path drin.
Ich weiß nicht, was...
Ich weiß nicht, was Go-Install jetzt überhaupt...
Wow.
Okay, erstmal 30.000 Sachen.
Ist das jetzt installiert?
Nee.
Wo installiert Go denn überhaupt was hin?
Ah, okay, da gibt's noch andere.
Oh, Go installiert noch Go.
Die haben auch keinen Bock, das Verzeichnis irgendwie zu verstecken oder so, gell?
Das juckt die nicht.
Also kann ich jetzt quasi nach Go-Bin-Air gehen und dann einfach Punkt oder so?
Ah.
Okay, jetzt ändere ich hier mal was.
Äh.
Matrix.
Ach ja.
Nice, gefällt mir.
Hat was.
Excellent.
Das ist der Chat.
Deswegen mag ich euch.
Ihr seid so high IQ, was das angeht.
So, und jetzt checkt er auch, dass er's restarten muss.
Running.
Ja, ja, ja.
Macht er.
Guck mal.
Curl.
Matrix.
Funst.
Restart.
Not found.
Geht.
Cool.
Das ist ein nices Projekt.
Das gefällt mir.
Chico.
Chico guckt auch ganz begeistert.
Okay, wie exportiere ich denn jetzt hier was?
Also, must register.
Da, da geht das doch irgendwie drüber.
Also hier, requesterations.
Der legt hier was an.
Aha.
So funst das.
Also.
Also, brauche ich quasi sowas wie, nennen wir es mal, nennen wir es mal hier irgendwie,
äh, last block oder so.
Ja.
Ach nee, Moment.
Doppelpunkt gleich.
Weil, weil go.
Jetzt sagt er, not in use.
Ja, ist gut.
Ist gut.
Und jetzt, new registry und dann, ach hier, einfach reinschreiben.
Was jetzt?
Too many arguments.
Ach nee, must register musst du es rein.
Äh.
Is invalid.
Is not a valid metric name.
Okay, name.
Name von der metric.
Is, ja.
Last block.
Gibt das, gibt das eine naming convention für Metrics?
Mit Underscore, glaube ich, gell?
Prometheus, Prometheus, Metric Naming Convention.
Ja, mit Underscore, genau.
Also, heißt das Ding, last block curl not found.
Guck, last block null.
Nice.
Wir kriegen, das ist, okay.
Da habe ich am Anfang echt zu Unrecht drüber geflamed, dass es kompliziert aussieht.
Bis jetzt finde ich das eigentlich sehr kurz, knackig und nice.
Das, das hat was.
Okay, was ist, was ist Subsystem und Namespace?
Keckel.
Const Labels.
Okay, help ist das da?
Was ist das?
Ist das normalerweise nicht immer in, in, in geschweiften Klammern dahinter, wenn man die gleiche Metric hat für verschiedene, ja, ähm, verschiedene, wie nennt man das dann?
Einheiten?
Oder mache ich das mit Labels in dem Fall dann?
Make labels.
Labels?
Jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich überfragt, wie das funzt.
Was?
Was will der hier von mir?
Er will, äh, wir bauen einen Prometheus Exporter.
In Go.
Und ich habe noch nie einen Prometheus Exporter richtig in Kompletten gebaut, in Go.
Aber, was will der denn hier überhaupt jetzt von mir?
Ich, da, da bin ich zu Go-Noob für.
Gucken wir mal uns die Examples an.
Hat er da irgendwas mit Const Labels drin?
Wie muss denn das?
Wie muss das aussehen?
Äh.
Du hast doch einen Exporter für mehrere Nodes, oder kannst du dann ja Labels?
Ja, ich habe, lass, oh, das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich habe die, das Deployment potenziell mehrfach drauf, ja.
Das muss ja dann irgendwie Unique sein, wobei das ist schon Unique, weil es beim Collecten als Label ja den, den Source mitkriegt, von wo das kommt.
Also, also eigentlich brauche ich gar keine Labels.
In dem Fall.
Aber mich würde trotzdem interessieren, wie das, wie das, äh, funzt, nämlich ich muss mal kurz ein Beispiel mir angucken, da bin ich zu, zu, zu, zu Noob, äh, für, aha, so.
Was?
So ganz, das habe ich auch nicht gecheckt.
Okay, Prometheus Labels Name, also quasi sowas muss ich da reinmachen.
Name und das andere ist, Value is Kekkel, okay.
So, und jetzt, äh, Change Detected.
Jetzt hat er es hier, ja, naja, okay, okay, ja, gut zu wissen.
Also, Subsystem schmeißen wir raus, Namespace, mein Namespace, Namespace, and name all complements of the fully qualified name of the metric, only name is mandatory, ja.
Ja, das lassen wir jetzt erstmal weg.
Help, ja, da denken wir uns einen schönen, schönen Text für aus.
Okay, alles klar, ja.
Ja, äh, funzt.
Okay, ähm, dann heißt das jetzt im Endeffekt, wenn ich jetzt mal angenommen, wir faken jetzt mal, wir faken jetzt mal, dass sich, dass sich das ändert, okay.
Das, das heißt wir machen mal so ein Background, so ein Background, äh, Threat quasi, so ein Get, wie nennt sich das?
Background Go Routine.
Ähm, so ging das, na, Go Funk.
Und dann sagen wir Wild, ne, Wildschleife.
Da gibt's, ah, Moment, das ist ja Go.
Es gibt ja keine Wildschleife, es gibt ja nur Vorschleifen.
For True.
Und jetzt setzen wir mal da irgendwie Counter Increment.
Okay.
Das brauchen wir nicht, einfach nur For Condition is Redundant.
Äh, Moment, Moment, Stopp, Stopp, Stopp, das ist jetzt, das ist eine etwas zu schnelle Endlosschleife.
Wenn ich das jetzt starte, hab ich instant erstmal eine CPU voll.
Das ist vielleicht nicht so geil.
Aber er updatet, der updatet halt ein bisschen schneller als notwendig.
Hehehe.
Time, Sleep, und das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt diese Go-Geschichte, Duration.
Wie ging das nochmal?
Time, Seconds, und dann quasi so mal eins für eine Sekunde, irgendwie so, gell.
Oder mal zwei für zwei Sekunden.
Ah, Milli, Milliseconds.
Nee.
Milliseconds, mal 500.
Okay, also quasi jede halbe Sekunde die Metrik updaten.
Funzt.
Wenn ich zu schnell bin, funzt nicht.
Guck, aber es funzt.
Okay, Metrik wird geupdatet.
Das mag ich echt an Go.
Für so kleinen Kram ist das ziemlich kurz und schmerzlos, ja.
So, das andere ist, das andere ist, das andere ist, das andere ist, das andere ist, das andere ist, das andere ist, das andere ist.
So, das updatet die Metrik.
Gut.
Nächster Punkt ist, wir tun jetzt einfach mal so, was wird gebaut?
Achso, nee, habe ich ja schon beantwortet, gell.
Habe ich schon, ja.
Wir bauen Prometheus-Exporter.
So, wir tun, wir tun jetzt einfach mal so, als hätte ich hier den Kram laufen.
Ich brauche übrigens lokal noch einen Prometheus, um das zu scrapen, und einen Grafana.
Das werde ich, das starte ich einfach irgendwie im Docker und greife dann drauf zu.
Ähm, machen wir das doch jetzt erstmal schnell.
Hier, Docker, Run, Grafana.
Ich glaube, man kann das einfach so ausführen, ohne irgendwas.
Man kann einfach sagen, ja, genau.
Nicht Grafana Enterprise, alter.
Und auch nicht Background für Border-Ground-Port 3000.
Jawoll, geb ihm, bam.
Ja.
Achso, Grafana, Grafana ist das Image, ja.
Yep, Glock.
Findet dein Exporter denn die existierenden No-
What the fuck?
Äh, mein Exporter ist ein Sidecar in einem Kubernetes-Deployment.
Der ist Bestandteil von einem Node.
Oder von einer Instanz, die da läuft.
Der kann einfach auf localhost die Sachen abfragen.
Und dann als Prometheus-Metriken exportieren.
So.
Jetzt heißt es, jetzt habe ich auf localhost 3000...
Ein Grafana.
Oh, Default, Default-Name...
Admin, Admin, glaube, gell?
Ne, Admin Grafana.
Kam das nicht?
Doch, ist 123456.
123456.
Sodmit.
Easy.
Eats.
So, haben wir unser Grafana am Start.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch einen Prometheus.
Prometheus.
Kann man das nicht einfach mal so hier installieren über...
Ja.
Brauche ich eine Prometheus-Jagd?
Mal testweise, um zu gucken, ob das funzt.
Und dann starten wir mal unser Grafana.
Gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Also.
Ähm.
Oh.
Prometheus.
Jamel.
Kann ich mir nicht merken, wie das Basic-mäßig aussieht.
Hier.
Da.
Basic.
Prometheus.
Jamel.
Bom.
Bam.
Äh.
Scrape-Intervall.
5 Sekunden.
Internal Labels.
Romanet.
Dokumentation ist überflüssig.
Static.
Config.
Target.
Wir targeten Local Host Port 8080.
Ist das...
Wobei.
Brauche ich das überhaupt, wenn ich das hier schon hab?
So.
Und jetzt kann ich sagen, Prometheus.
Äh.
Config.
Es muss Prometheus-Jamel heißen.
Ah ja.
Und nicht Jamel, sondern Prometheus-Jimmel.
Chatge.
Wie heißt das?
Prometheus.
Jamel.
newton die data source data source data source prometheus atp local host port
90 90 müsste es sein keine authentifizierung passt alles safe
und 3.000 3.000 kaffee auf welchem port läuft es läuft es jetzt 90 90 90 90
läuft ist dass graf anna will ich ja an den was hat er für schmerzen ist auch da
was das brauche ich dafür auch gar nicht was
was was was was was was was was was was was was was was was was was was was was was was
was hat er jetzt für ach so lokal aus geht ja nicht weil graf anna im container
läuft all da ist ja logisch da muss ich ja meine ich habe meine ip angeben von
dem prometheus drauf läuft ja ja schon besser schon besser okay alles klar home
alles klar explorer last block er hat schon erkannt er hat schon erkannt ja
mein counter ist mittlerweile bei ja guck da er hat er hat meinen meinen kram schon ab
abgepickt ok da ist jetzt jetzt können wir nämlich ordentlich testen jetzt kann
man sich ordentlich ausprobieren indem ich den ganzen wenn ich den den den mist
hier drin habe ok freuen alles klar jetzt können wir mal so tun polygon scan
jetzt jetzt können wir ja mal so tun als als hätten wir einen blog channel laufen
latest blogs ja exakt der blog das ist das was mich wahnsinnig interessiert
last blog den updaten wir jetzt einfach mal nicht okay dann bleibt jetzt bleibt
jetzt fertig immer auf dem gleichen value wie setzt man eigentlich ein value
description hammer
channel ok keine ahnung das mit so
ich hab ja einen counter ich will ja gar kein counter wenn ich einfach irgendwelche
werte setzen möchte dann will ich kein counter sondern ich glaube eine eine
gauche eine moment bin ja auch bin ja auch ein noob doch hier falsch ich will
ja auch you gau gau was hier
opt opt
Alles klar. Hat das jetzt reloaded?
Machen wir hier curl.
Äh.
Curl auf das Matrix.
Ja.
23. Okay. Okay.
Das kann man jetzt zwar incrementen, das will ich aber nicht.
Jetzt kann man jetzt aber auch, jetzt kann man den Wert auf jeden Fall setzen.
Klar.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich brauche übrigens mal meine Keybindings.
Das nervt mich.
Äh.
VS Code?
Checkt er das dann?
Ah. Nice.
Jetzt habe ich meine Standard Keybindings,
die ich auswendig kenne.
Zumindest die wichtigsten.
Herr Crusher. Moin.
Also. Jetzt heißt das aber auch.
Genau. So. Wie kann ich den?
Ich will den Wert einmalig jetzt setzen.
Last Block.
Add.
Set.
Wahrscheinlich.
Kann man in Prometheus irgendwie sagen,
welche Unit
diese Metrik hat?
Oder muss man das rein im Frontend einstellen und wissen?
Also in Grafana kann man ja einstellen,
dieser Wert ist, äh, keine Ahnung.
Unix, Timestamp, äh, oder Seconds,
oder Megabytes, oder sowas.
Prometheus kann ja nur, kann ja nur zahlen im Endeffekt.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob man Prometheus quasi schon auch exportieren lassen kann.
Welche Unit das Ganze ist.
Glaube nicht.
Ich glaub, das musste, ich glaubte, das musste dann hier in die, in die Hilfe reinschreiben.
So. Jetzt bekomme ich den letzten Block.
Dann müsste die Unit in Grafana noch so oder so händisch.
Ja, muss so.
Es wär halt cool, wenn man das schon.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es einfach in den Hilfetext rein.
Laut Convention sollte der Metrik-Namen die Unit am Ende enthalten.
Okay.
Dann ist es wahrscheinlich auch besser, guckt mal.
Dann ist es wahrscheinlich auch besser, wenn ich die Metrik so nenne, oder?
Last Block ID.
Dann weiß man nämlich,
das ist gar keine Einheit, sondern das ist halt die Unique ID von dem Block.
Was findet ihr besser?
Last Block oder Last Block ID?
Ich glaube, Last Block ID ist besser, weil dann können wir auch sowas machen wie Last Block Timestamp und sowas.
Ja, nehmen wir erst mal Last Block ID.
Moment.
Wir können auch einfach die Rename-Funktion verwenden, die aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht hiermit aufblockt in GoLand.
Warum nicht?
Hät.
Die.
Refactor.
Rename.
Äh.
ID.
Wat?
Was?
Okay.
Ich dachte, das macht der einfach so.
Okay, das Ding heißt...
Last Block ID.
Dann brauchen wir noch Last Block...
Äh.
Time?
Last Block...
Wie würde man das Ding jetzt nennen?
Also, mal angenommen, ich will jetzt was mit einem Timestamp.
Dann heißt das Ding...
Soll ich es...
Last...
Block...
TS nennen?
Oder soll ich...
Soll ich...
Soll ich es...
Also, das Ding ist ja...
Also, ein Timestamp kann ja verschiedene Formate haben.
Gehen wir mal von aus, das wäre Unix-Time.
Würde ich das dann TS-UNIX?
Oder wie...
Wie ist das eine gute...
Wie ist eine gute Benamung dafür?
Wahrscheinlich Last Block TS.
Und in Hilfe würde ich dann quasi reinschreiben...
Äh...
Creation Time of Last Block in Unix-Time oder sowas.
Oh!
Mein Auge!
Alter.
Naming.
A magic name must comply...
It should be a single word...
Unit.
Must have a single unit.
Ach, guck mal hier!
Timestamp...
For a timestamp that tracks the time of the latest...
Processed timestamp seconds.
Okay.
Das sagt aber immer noch nicht, dass das Unix-Time ist.
Aber das finde ich okay.
Okay.
Würdest du, Andreas, würdest du da ID hintendran hängen, damit das klarer ist, was das ist?
Das ist...
Ist das keine Unit?
Aber es ergibt schon Sinn, dass du weißt, dass es keine Unit braucht.
Okay, das finde ich...
Das ist aber okay so.
Und in der Hilfe steht dann eben das, was Unix-Time-Seconds ist.
Nicht Milliseconds.
Da sind die sich ja immer nicht so einig.
Seconds since 1970 ist das, glaube ich, gell?
Ja.
Aber das ist okay.
Das finde ich nice.
So, Prometheus-Labels und so.
Das können wir vielleicht später irgendwas machen.
Also.
Die ID bleibt gleich.
Da muss ich mir jetzt keine Gedanken machen.
Aber der Timestamp...
Der Timestamp ist echt so ein Ding.
Das muss ich jetzt von...
Polygon-Scan abfragen.
Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt ein HTTP-Request machen zu Polygon-Scan.
Polygon-Scan-API.
Kann man das auch ohne API-Key verwenden?
Oh no.
Geht das auch ohne API-Key?
Please, lasst mich eure API ohne API-Key verwenden.
Und blendet mich nicht so.
Blendet mich nicht.
Das ist mir zu hell.
Splixxer, danke für den Sub.
Ich brauche eine API-Key.
Oh, ich brauche eine API-Key.
Wisst ihr was?
Wir faken das jetzt einfach.
Wir crappen uns das da raus.
Weil was mich interessiert ist hier.
Dieser Timestamp.
Der interessiert mich.
Passen wir auf.
Wir curren.
Wir webscrapen das jetzt.
Jawoll.
Perfekt.
Und wie heißt das hier?
Timestamp?
Less?
Timestamp.
What the f...
Hier!
Ah!
Guck mal!
Da steht ja sogar direkt in UNIX-Time drin!
Okay, also.
Show UTC Localdate.
Ich crappe...
Ich crappe nach Data Timestamp.
Curl minus S.
Ja.
Wobei.
Moment.
Ich crappe...
Ich crappe da gar nichts.
Ich muss das ja in go machen.
kreppen. Ja? Okay.
Ich kreppe nach Timestamp.
Wir machen das mal ganz kurz in
Bash. Dann
cutten wir das Ganze am
Gleichheitszeichen. Nehmen wir das dritte Feld.
Ne?
Öh.
Ne, wir
splitten nicht am Gleichheitszeichen.
Wir splitten an...
Wir splitten an da dran.
Excellent.
Excellent. So, und das ist
Unix-Time.
Das sieht nach Unix-Time
Seconds aus, oder?
Ja, ja, ja. Das ist eindeutig
Unix-Time Seconds.
Alles klar. Okay.
Es ist High-IQ, Andreas.
Das mit Lookaheads
und Dings. Und ich bin mir
gar nicht sicher, wie dieses Konstrukt
korrekt jetzt heißt.
Aber allein schon, wenn man in
Crab-Pearl-Regex einschalten muss,
dann weiß man, irgendwas ist falsch.
Sobald man Pearl-Regex braucht in Crab
ist irgendwie
sass. Ich bleib
bei meinem. Ich finde, das ist besser lesbar.
Aber davon abgesehen, wir können das in Go eh nicht
machen, weil in Go können wir nicht crappen und
cutten. Wie macht man ein Web-Request
in Go? Jetzt geht's
los, Leute. Ich kommentiere
diesen ganzen Crab-Pil mal aus, weil ich nicht
weiß aus dem Kopf, wie man ein Web-Request in Go
macht.
HTTP get in Go.
Jawoll.
Net-HTTP.
Da macht man einfach
http.get
eats
eatsie.
So. Und jetzt
sowas. Response.
Ah, Moment. Jetzt muss ich ja Error-Handling machen.
Naja, da schlägt ja eh nix fehl.
Wird kein Error gehandelt.
Was ist das hier?
Error-Handling.
Keck. Okay, Error.
Ja, man sollte.
Web-Request sollte man schon
erroren.
Und wie war das jetzt nochmal in Go?
Warum kann das hier die...
Warum kann die IDE
mir kein Error-Handling generieren?
Muss man...
Wie war das? If...
If R,
gell?
Und dann kannst du sagen...
Ja, das soll dann
gar nicht crashen.
Weiß ich noch
nicht genau, was dann passiert.
So, und in der
Response. Moment, das war doch in
Go so, du kannst die Response nicht einfach
lesen. Du musst doch irgendwie sowas machen.
I-O-Read-All
oder irgendwie sowas, gell?
War das nicht so? Ne.
Body?
Ja, so war das. Genau.
FMT-Brindeln.
Nicht Brindeln.
Brindeln?
Okay.
Hat das jetzt funktioniert?
Moin, Patrick.
Run. Nein, will nicht. Warum?
Was?
Was ist?
Syntax.
Unexpected new line in argument list.
Possible missing... Achso, was?
Oh, das
fuckt mich halt immer echt ab an Go, das
Zeug hier. Ob... Es ist gar nicht
das Problem. Was?
Äh...
Ah.
Ich hab die Klammer nicht zugemacht.
Was ist der
Vorteil von Go?
Oh mein...
Ach, ich muss erst noch sagen, dass es ein
String ist, gell?
Ja.
Kann ich noch irgendwie sagen, String oder so?
Nee, Moment, das war Python-Kram.
Äh...
Moment.
Stack... Stack-Overflow. Stack-Overflow.
Go, http, response, s, string. Da gibt's doch bestimmt was kürzeres, wie das ich da...
Ja, genau.
Tatsächlich, man muss es ernsthaft so machen.
Da gibt es nix kürzeres als das.
Ja, Go ist manchmal schon ein bisschen weird, weird champ.
Und...
Auf der anderen Seite, eines der Sachen von
Go ist ja...
Äh...
Nee.
Warum?
Und...
Wie jetzt?
Hä?
Hab ich doch gemacht.
Ach so, das kann auch fehlschlagen.
Ach, das kann auch fehlschlagen.
Okay.
Okay, ist ja gut, Go.
Aber das ist mir egal, ob das fehlschlägen kann.
Das wird jetzt einfach...
So, und jetzt aber, ha?
Nee, Moment.
Moment, das ist ja kein...
Das ist ja kein...
Nee, Moment.
Moment, das ist ja kein String.
Das ist, äh...
Wie nennt man das hier?
B!
Guck, der weiß auch nicht, wie er es nennen soll, weil er es einfach B nennt.
B.
Bester.
So, und jetzt?
String.
So, ne?
So, alles klar.
So.
Jetzt muss...
Gekreppt werden in Go.
Okay.
Ähm...
Hey, Gags, ja?
Aber gibt es nicht sowas wie...
Ich lupe all of them?
Ja.
Geht das nicht irgendwie ein bisschen einfacher?
Ne, das ist nur für Grab, weil das O das sonst nicht matcht, gell?
Das brauchen wir gar nicht so kompliziert zu machen.
Ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt einfach suchen.
Kennst du Rekkex 1? Ja, das kenne ich.
Ich kenne auch Rekkex Lab und solche.
Da können wir das machen, aber wir probieren es jetzt mal so.
Also Start ist mir eigentlich...
Warum sind das Backticks, Leute?
Warum sind das Backticks und keine Quotes?
Was sind denn...
Kann man jetzt für Strings in Go auch sowas hier machen neuerdings?
Oder wie? Ne, kann man nicht.
Doch kann man.
Was ist das?
Was ist... Kann man da jetzt Variablen einsetzen oder irgendwas?
Oder was ist... Hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Backticks für Strings in Go.
Okay, wir suchen nach...
Data Timestamp.
Sind das vielleicht Rekkex Strings?
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie dafür...
Einen eigenen Typ haben.
Gut, das ist ein String.
Ne, das ist ein ganz normaler String.
Das könnte man auch...
Das ist vielleicht ein String, der irgendwie keine...
Ne, dann weiß ich nicht.
Use raw strings to avoid having to quote the backslashes.
Aha.
Okay.
Also.
Wie kriegen wir das denn jetzt raus?
TS Rekkex?
Find.
Ah, guck mal.
Da kann man direkt...
Kann man das so machen?
Ne.
Aber man kann hier...
Body.
Aha.
Okay.
Find.
Was kommt da jetzt raus?
Null.
Okay.
Hat er nicht gefunden.
Aber warum nicht?
Timestamp kommt da drin vor.
Muss ich...
Punkt...
Muss ich sagen Punkt Sternchen?
Timestamp?
Äh.
Hä?
Ähm.
Das nicht.
Okay.
Da muss ein D drin vorkommen.
A D kommt drin vor.
Okay.
Und Data?
Data kommt drin...
Ach.
Wegen dem...
Wegen dem Minus vielleicht?
Oder...
Kommt da drin Timestamp vor?
What?
Was ist das für Magic?
Okay.
Vielleicht...
Find on.
Okay.
Jetzt bin ich zu pipiga.
Das zu checken,
wie das ist.
das funktioniert das krebs geht noch habe ich immer ausgeführt guck was
funks wie wirst du das nicht erst ein string hat ich ja eben auch schon
ausprobiert match match string ist jetzt ist jetzt ja einer guck wenn ich das ja
ausgebe ob es wenn ich das ja ausgebe brindeln dann kommt die webseite dabei
raus und in der webseite ist crepe im stamp jetzt ist doch genau das gleiche
was ich hier gettet warum ist hier warum ist hier timestamp drin und jetzt nicht
heißt detekten die irgendwie das ist ein
gold
abfrage ist und deswegen deswegen darf ich nicht oder oder was ist das die
seite sieht auch ganz anders aus was ist das für eine seite das ist das
irgendein dedos schutz oder challenge oh nein das mit köln funktioniert ohne
probleme okay was was für was für hätte setzt köln denn da
d Vas von was buradan ist da ein Resources
user agent wo ist der user seht ihr denn gerade http2 jetzt wollen sie es aber
eine option für header das wäre auch zu einfach wenn man daher der option setzen
könnte go http get header how to set headers new request
ach okay aha alles klar alles klar okay ja okay
kommt das hier weg okay request error wird nicht gehen fort alle error
handling keck wait new requests get so wie war das jetzt hier request header
add und da wollen wir jetzt
so wie war das jetzt hier request header add und da wollen wir jetzt
so wie war das jetzt hier request header add und da wollen wir jetzt user agent
user agent
user agent das wäre natürlich so schreiben weil das
das wäre natürlich so schreiben weil das
das wäre natürlich so schreiben weil das einfach zu kommen zu einfach wäre sonst
einfach zu kommen zu einfach wäre sonst
einfach zu kommen zu einfach wäre sonst so und jetzt kann ich wahrscheinlich
so und jetzt kann ich wahrscheinlich
so und jetzt kann ich wahrscheinlich sagen request send request send request
sagen request send request send request
sagen request send request get get get body und das jetzt du okay das ist
get get body und das jetzt du okay das ist
get get body und das jetzt du okay das ist ja super eklig man klein du wer hat
ja super eklig man klein du wer hat
ja super eklig man klein du wer hat sich die abi dann ausgedacht man da
sich die abi dann ausgedacht man da
Da lecke ich aber gern
Critical Information, dass ich bisher nicht wusste,
wie das in Go funktioniert.
So, und jetzt
sage ich wahrscheinlich Response und
wieder Error.
Da gibt es doch bestimmt schon tausende
HTTP-Client-Wrapper
für Go, dass das nicht so eklig ist.
So, und jetzt können wir mal gucken, ob es jetzt
funktioniert. Aha,
jetzt funktioniert es. Okay, easy.
Easy. User-Agent-Curl.
Das ist the way.
Das brauchen wir.
So, und jetzt
Compile Match String
True.
True
0w
Pint
String
Timestamp. Okay, Funst.
Alles klar. Gut, hat funktioniert.
Hat funktioniert.
Okay, Timestamp.
So, und jetzt müssen wir extra hier
jetzt müssen wir sowas wie Matching Group machen.
Jetzt müssen wir sowas wie Matching Group machen.
Okay, Timestamp gleich.
Wie sah das nochmal aus?
Data
Timestamp.
Okay, Timestamp gleich.
Also, Timestamp gleich. Mal gucken, ob
das das kann.
Und dann Non-Cready Match.
Okay.
Passt.
Ach, nee, Moment. Es muss
Anführungszeichen sein.
Nice. So, und jetzt ist die Frage
Matching Groups
Question Mark.
Wie kann ich da jetzt drauf zugreifen?
Group
Match
Find all String
Submatch.
Oh.
String int.
What?
Okay.
Go Rack X Match Group.
How to get
Capturing Group. Jawohl.
Wie geht das?
Reference, Capture, Name, 3, Sub,
Express. Was?
Was?
Was wollt ihr von mir?
Ich check's nicht.
Kannst du doch nicht einfach Substring machen?
Ja, das
wahrscheinlich könnte ich mir das rausholen
und dann splitten.
Ich könnte splitten, aber ich mein
Aber es muss doch irgendwie
Matching Groups geben
in Go.
What?
Was?
Find String Submatch, ok?
Also was?
Find String
Sub
Match.
Okay.
Ich kann bestimmt noch sagen
Find Submatch oder find string
Submatch Das ist, das ist richtig.
Panes Chamber.
Ein Strings Submatch.
Ah ja okay.
Und da kann ich jetzt quasi.
Sie sagen ArrayIndex1
wahrscheinlich.
Oh.
Eats. Eats. Eats. Eats.
Okay.
Timestamp gleich das da.
FMT Brindeln.
Timestamp.
Jetzt können wir übrigens wieder
R benutzen.
Ja. Nice. Okay.
Das müssen wir jetzt alle paar Sekunden
machen. Wobei
der Timestamp ändert sich ja
nicht.
Naja. Wir tun jetzt mal als
ändert sich aber der Last Block. Okay.
Sind wir mal nicht so.
Also. Ich will zwei Sachen damit
machen. Anmetrigen.
Das kann ich
mir mal copy pasten.
Den Client
können wir uns wahrscheinlich hier oben
speichern.
Den
Request.
Den müssen wir aber
ändern.
Und dann jedes Mal, wenn sich, na gut, der Block ändert sich jetzt gerade nicht.
Wir faken das mal.
Okay. Also. Wir haben einmal
LastBlockID.
Und dann haben wir
LastBlockTime.
LastBlockTime lese ich jetzt gerade hier
da drüber aus.
So.
Dann kommentieren wir den ganzen
Spodder mal wieder ein.
Also das ist die ID.
Die bleibt immer fest. Das ist okay so.
In der
Function alle
Sagen wir mal. Wir wollen uns ja mal nicht blocken lassen.
Okay. Alle 5 Sekunden
der Rest
passt. Fragen wir das hier ab.
Da kann man
doch bestimmt eine eigene Function hier machen.
Get
Block. Ach ja. Wie ist denn die
GoNamingConvention? Ist es
GetBlockTS oder ist es
GetBlock
Wahrscheinlich ist es so.
TS
Da machen wir jetzt irgendwie
Float64
BlockID
Ne Moment. Ha.
Das ist ja Go. Das ist so rum.
Kann man
Moment. Kann man sowas machen
wie ConstClient?
Ne. Natürlich nicht.
Das wäre zu einfach.
War Client?
Ja. Okay. Das funzt.
Dann schmeißen wir
das weg.
Hier Request.
Und dann
Return
Timestamp.
Ach ja. Man muss ja angeben, dass der was
Return. Und zwar soll der
Warum kann der das nicht automatisch für mich aus?
Ach doch. Geht doch. Genau.
So. Jetzt kriege ich hier den String zurück.
Wenn ich dem Block
übergebe. Der Block ist das hier.
Das hardcoden wir jetzt mal. Also alle
paar Sekunden. Also die ID
müssen wir nicht
incrementen. Das macht keinen Sinn.
Also wir sagen jetzt alle
5 Sekunden.
Get Block
TS. So.
Dann übergeben wir die Block ID.
Und dann
setzen wir Last Block
Time Set
auf
Ja.
String ist eigentlich doof.
Ich hätte das gleich
Ich sollte da
gleich einen Flow zurückgeben und gar kein
String.
Macht ja keinen Sinn.
Kann man
wie passt man in Go?
Ein String als Float.
So wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ist das AOT?
Nee. Wie heißt dieser Krempel?
Go String
to Float.
Oder ist es Float 64
und dann irgendwas mit
Atoi war das.
Genau. Atoi. Das kann
sein, dass ich das meine.
Str Conf
What?
Between Float and String.
String.
String Conf Pass Float.
Warum ist das nicht
irgendein
irgendwas in der Float 64
Klasse oder Klasse stimmt ja nicht
Typ.
String Conf
Float
Pass Float
Was? Bit Size Int?
What?
Oh, das ist ja eklig.
Warum heißt es nicht Pass Float
32 und Pass Float 64?
Okay, Pass Float
String
Timestamp
Das checkt der jetzt, oder wie?
Bin ja mal gespannt.
Okay, ja dann
return auch noch nen Error.
So what? Okay.
Kann ja immer alles erroren
im Zweifelsfall, wenn er es mal nicht findet.
Alles gut.
Go.
Besser.
Erst mal alles
diskan.
Okay, jetzt funzt es, oder?
Ja, guck mal.
Er gibt es aus.
Und ersetzt es hoffentlich.
Oder auch nicht.
Also, und ersetzt es. Okay, wenn ich jetzt nen Curl
da drauf mache, dann sollte ich
das als
von meinem Exporter bekommen.
Äh.
Das ist vermutlich das
Richtige.
Ist ein bisschen haarig.
Oder ein bisschen hakelig in manchen
Fällen. Das Gute an Go
ist, was
was man eigentlich schon irgendwie zu
schätzen wissen muss,
dass Go relativ wenig Magic
macht. In Go musst du jeden
Furz explizit hinschreiben.
Zum größten Teil zumindest.
Die haben sich ja auch jahrelang geweigert
sowas wie Array
Map oder sowas anzubieten.
Ich glaube, das haben die immer noch nicht, oder?
Wisst ihr, was die Go-Standard-Antwort ist?
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt nen Array, ja?
So. So, und ihr wollt es jetzt
filtern. Filter nach
Wir tun jetzt einfach mal so, als wüsst ihr was.
Filter alle Elemente,
wo X größer als 4 ist.
Das geht ja in Go so nicht.
Wisst ihr, was Go
sagt? Go sagt, mach ne
Vorschleife mit nem If drinne.
Das ist mir dann doch ein bisschen zu viel
des Guten. Bisschen zu viel des, wie soll man sagen,
äh, raw
raw bleiben, ja?
Das liegt aber nicht wirklich an
Go, sondern das liegt an Rust.
Wenn du C-Sharp mit
Rust verglichen
hättest, hättest du das gleiche
gehabt. Oder wenn du JavaScript
mit Rust verglichen hättest,
hättest du das gleiche gehabt. Ich behaupte
sogar, in den Sprachen wärst du gar noch schneller
gewesen als in Go.
Aber bei Go geht's schon in Ordnung.
Der große Vorteil von Go,
übrigens jetzt mal nicht auf die Sprache selbst
bezogen, der große Vorteil, was in Go
zu programmieren, sind self-contained Binary.
Go eignet sich super,
um die Anwendung simpel
zu vercontainerisieren.
Du kriegst ein Binary raus, das kopierst du in deinen
Container und es ist fertig.
Es geht einfach. Wisst du, ich hab's schon
lange nicht mehr in Daoog gesehen.
Ja, und wenn du es zuerst
in Rust gemacht hast, hat's ja vielleicht auch ein bisschen
ein bisschen schneller
das in Go programmiert.
Surrendered, warum?
Es macht Bock, best game ever.
Also, wir haben jetzt den Timestamp
gesetzt. Dann lasst uns aber grad mal ins
Grafana gucken.
Wobei, noch sehen wir in unserem
Grafana ja gar nix. Wir müssen jetzt noch ne
wir brauchen noch ne Metric, Leute.
Das ist, wir haben jetzt
LastBlockID
LastBlockTimestamp
und was wir jetzt noch
brauchen ist
LastBlock
ähm
Wie nennt man das?
Ich will jetzt ausrechnen, wie viel Zeit
vergangen ist.
Duration? Age. Age.
Nennen wir das. LastBlockAge.
Ich will, ich will gucken,
wie alt der Block ist. Also, relativ
zur aktuellen Zeit.
Oh, das heißt, wir müssen DateTimeCalculations
in Go machen?
Das wird, das wird Painstamp, ich ahne
es jetzt schon.
So, das ist LastBlock
Darf man das? AgeSeconds
Ist das, ist das die
korrekte Go-Schreibweise?
Lasst uns von Grafana
ausrechnen.
Das würde funktionieren, tatsächlich,
ja.
Das, das würde in dem Fall funktionieren,
weil du in Prometheus, also Grafana
rechnet das ja nicht aus, weil du in Prometheus
glaube ich, eine
TimeDifferent
oder sowas Function hast, ja.
Das könntste machen.
Aber, wir machen's jetzt trotzdem
mal, weil ich
wissen will, wie das funktioniert.
Klar, ich, ich spiel das bis nächste
Season. Ich will, ich will mal, okay,
da, da machen wir das, doch, wir machen das
jetzt mal, weil ich wissen will, ob's,
ob's, ob's funktioniert. Wir nennen das mal LastAgeSeconds
Ist auch wurscht.
Und
jetzt setzen wir das,
ich möchte jetzt mal DateTimeMagic
LastBlock
AgeSet
Wir schreiben jetzt mal 1 rein, weil
weil Go sonst
nervt. Also,
wie würden wir das ausrechnen?
Ich habe jetzt
ein
Timestamp in
UnixTime
Wie krieg ich in Go
Golang
UnixTime
Wie kann ich in Go
ein
DateTimeObjekt erzeugen
aus einem UnixTimeStamp
Und wie kann ich in Go
überhaupt Sachen voneinander abziehen?
Also, ich will sowas wie TimeNow
haben, sowas gibt's doch, oder?
So, im Prinzip will ich sowas hier machen.
Ja
Age
oder Duration oder wie auch immer.
Im Prinzip will ich sowas machen.
Es gibt TimeUnix
Ja, wirklich?
Ach, also im Prinzip will ich
TimeUnix
und keine Nanoseconds.
Das funktioniert natürlich nicht.
Warum?
Warum nicht? Warum Go?
Warum kann ich das nicht voneinander abziehen?
Warum funnst du das nicht?
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
InvalidOperation
Ach, es ist kein MinusOperator
Ich muss von Sub machen.
Ok, TS
geht nicht. Warum?
Cannot use TS type float
64S type
in64
Ok, also müssen wir das jetzt
wahrscheinlich casten
Was ist denn nur mit casten los?
So
Wir sind ja in Go
Wir sollten das so machen
Das kann natürlich wieder wahrscheinlich fehlschlagen
Deswegen ignorieren wir einfach den Error
Ne, der Mac hat das die Variablen nicht
Ok, last block
age set
Moment, duration
Das ist jetzt ein duration Objekt
Wie kriege ich ein duration Objekt
in seconds?
Ah, hier, float 64
Excellent
By the way, warum hat er nicht erkannt, dass er reloaden soll?
Er ist gecrashed
Nice
Bam
No run
Curl
Warum exportiert er nur block ID?
Ah, weil ich
noob bin
Weil ich nur block ID exportiere
Ich muss eigentlich noch last block time
und last block age
Aha
Ja
Das funzt, Leute
Wenn er aktualisiert nur alle 5 Sekunden
Ja
Guck mal
Nice, nice, nice, nice, funzt
Ähm
Jetzt gucken wir mal in unser Grafana rein
Ob er das da auch checkt
Ja
Last block age seconds
Nice
Ja, das ist ja cool
Gib mir schon
Time since
Ok
Das ist natürlich besser
Also quasi time
Ah
Da haben sie sich was gedacht
Bei Go
Bei den Go-Leuten
Ok, das gefällt mir aber ganz gut
Ja, das funzt hier tatsächlich
Guck mal
Last block age seconds instance und so ist dabei
Ja, cool
Alles ist besser als datetime in javascript
Haben die nicht
Vor einer ganzen Weile angekündigt
Javascript bekommt eine neue datetime-AP
Gibt es die mittlerweile schon?
Temporal oder so, genau
Can I use
Gucken wir mal
Temporal
Heißt das so?
Normalerweise geht das schneller
Also wenn das Sachen sind, wo die Hersteller
Scharf drauf sind
Implementieren die das in Browsern schon
Bevor das überhaupt standardisiert ist
Wobei es ist glaube ich noch nicht
Standardisiert, ne
Aber, und das muss man den
Javascript Leuten echt
Wirklich zugute halten
Wenn die was machen hat
Das Hand und Fuß
Nicht wie C++ das C++ Cremium
Wo du das Gefühl hast
Jeder der nur genug Einfluss in diesem Cremium hat
Kann da irgendwas
Irgendwas quasi, wie soll man sagen
Einbringen
Und das wird dann genommen
Und die C++ Standard Library funktioniert alles anders
Also das muss man echt sagen
Das Javascript Cremium macht meiner Meinung nach
Echt gute Arbeit
Wenn halt auch langsam
Was ist denn Can I Use auf dem Kabel
Ja
Safari Technology Preview
Und was sagt
Was wie sieht es denn mit
Firefox aus
Moment
Wollen die mir ernsthaft sagen
Safari hat was schneller
Als Chrome und Firefox
Ernsthaft
Ja ok
Technology Preview
Das glaube ich erst wenn ich sehe
Tatsächlich
Alter
Safari hat mal was zuerst
Dass ich das noch erleben darf
Safari ist eigentlich
Der neue Internet Explorer
Was Features angeht
Ja aber natürlich nur Desktop Safari
Ja IOS Safari selbstverständlich nicht
Iludl
Ich muss sagen
Die Go Library ist vielleicht auf den ersten Blick
Ein bisschen eklig
Aber auf den zweiten Blick jetzt muss ich sagen
Ist es relativ straight forward zu benutzen
Ich meine also der korrekte
Weg das zu machen wäre tatsächlich
Nicht mit Age
Sondern wir sagen
Last Block Timestamp Seconds
Jetzt bin ich
Jetzt bin ich aber aufgeschmissen weil ich nicht weiß
Wie man das in PromQL gescheit macht
Also hier Last Block Seconds
Das ist 1,71
Billions
Das ist Unix Time Seconds
Das sind Sekunden seit
1.1.1970
Und warum
Ist das so
Wenn man sich ausgedacht hat
Dass es ein gutes Zeitformat ist
Sekunden seit 1.1.1970
Manche machen auch Millisekunden
Seit 1.1.1970
Und es sind
1,71
Billionen Sekunden
Vergangen seit 1.1.1970
Wird das dann negativ
Wenn es vor dem 1.1. ist
Also
Theoretisch schon
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das überhaupt definiert ist
Also unter Linux
Es gibt keine Zeit
Vor dem 1.1.1970
Ja du könntest das schon
Negativ darstellen
Aber ich glaube das ist nicht etabliert
Die Zeitrechnung
Beginnt am 1.1.1970
In Unix Time
Das ist das
Das ist die Stunde 0 sozusagen
So jetzt müssen wir mal unsere
PromQL
Five Hats
Brauchen wir jetzt mal hier
Ähm so
Wir stellen das jetzt mal um
Wie
Time Function
Oh guck mal
Der Andreas weiß das bestimmt
Der hat sowas schon gemacht
Der wirkte vorher sehr five hat
Was das angeht
Wie würde ich jetzt mit PromQL
Das ausrechnen
Oder hast du nicht schon gar was geschrieben
Vorhin
Mal gucken
Ne
Also die Prometheus Metriken sind defined als
Float 6040
Die könnten theoretisch negativ sein
Range Functions
Time Functions
Day of Month
Ne das ergibt ja gar keinen Sinn
Es ist
Der
20.
Also Code
Also was
Time minus
Timestamp
Takt auch Unix Time Seconds
Will der also schon haben
Tatsächlich
Cool
Guck mal wie er das aus dem Kopf weiß
Da muss man wirklich ernsthaft mal sagen
Also der Chat hier ist schon
Most High IQ
Stellts auf ganz Twitch
Wo hast du sonst noch Leute auf Twitch
Die sowas wissen
Bei Amorant im
Pool Stream
Bestimmt nicht
Siehst sogar die einzelnen Steps
Ja
Um jetzt mal zu
Vergleichen wie akkurat
Das ganze hier ist
Und da trage ich mal mein
Age in Seconds ein
Run
Ja ist schon ziemlich ähnlich
Oder die blaue
Die grüne und
Die gelben Bars
Ist schon
Ziemlich ähnlich
Also das ich geb direkt
Ne das ist die deutlich schönere Variante
Hier
Habt ihr noch irgendeine Idee
Was für Metriken sinnvoll wären in dem Kontext
Ich hab ja hier schon öfters mal Sachen
Gefragt und die Leute hatten richtig
Neiße Ideen
Also die eigentliche
Das sind die drei Metriken die uns erstmal
Interessieren
Die letzte Block ID
Und das Age
Aber das Age wie gesagt
Nicht machen
Können wir uns selbst ausrechnen
So
Ich äh
Programmiere einen eigenen Prometheus Exporter
Jetzt weißt du Bescheid
Oder
Aber ich kanns dir auch genauer erklären
Prometheus ist
Eine Monitoring Software
Wo du Infos abfragen kannst
Von bestimmten Endpunkten
Kannst du zum Beispiel abfragen
Was ist das
Du kannst zum Beispiel über Prometheus abfragen
Wie voll ist die Festplatte auf meinem Server
So und dann ähm
Sammelst du das ein
Und dann kannst du hier in so einem
Graffing Tool wie Grafana die Infos dann auswählen
Da kannst du ja so einen Graph machen hier
Festplatten Füllstand über den letzten Monat
Natürlich kann Prometheus nicht nur so
Standardmetriken sammeln sondern auch
Eigene Metriken
Und wir brauchen dafür einen Node
Expor...ne nicht einen Node
Einen Exporter, einen Prometheus Exporter
Der diese Metriken exportiert
Und ich will für eine Blockchain Anwendung
Exportieren
Was die letzte Block ID ist
Und was die Block ID für einen
Timestamp hat
Damit man das dann hier
Grafisch darstellen kann
Und im Zweifelsfall auch direkt auf den ersten Blick sieht
Das Ding hängt weil sich die letzte Block ID
Quasi nicht ändert
Ja
Du hast Recht vielleicht soll ich das umbenennen
Ja es ist der letzte Block
Gemeint den der Node
Quasi gesehen hat
Oder der letzte Node
Den der gesynct hat im Endeffekt
Alert müssen wir mal gucken
Alert können wir aber easy machen
Wenn die Metrik da ist
Ja vielleicht sollte ich das dann nämlich nicht
Last...wobei doch ich nenne es
Last Block ID
Man könnte es auch Node Last Block ID nennen
Was sind sinnvolle Labels
Bei
Weil ich meine das könnte auch mehrfach
Im gleichen Kubernetes Cluster laufen
Wobei du kriegst ja extra Labels
Schon dran
Für die Instance und sowas
Also ich glaube wir brauchen ehrlich gesagt gar keine Labels
Doch Labels doch
Blockchain
Welche das ist
Weil das siehst du anhand der Werte ja nicht
Da muss Blockchain Polygon
Zum Beispiel rein in dem Fall
Das du weißt
Weil das Ding könnte ja auch was weiß ich
Bitcoin
Macht er nicht aber könnte ja auch
Oder es könnte auch
Machen
Und wenn da nicht Polygon dran steht ist natürlich blöd
Weil man weiß ja nicht was es ist
Ja da sollte schon Labels Blockchain Polygon dran stehen
Ja das ist sinnvoll
Excellent ist das
Und wisst ihr was noch nicer ist
Diese
Die Labels die könnte man sogar über eine
Über eine Environment Variable setzen lassen
Dann könntest du das nämlich in deinem Kubernetes Deployment
Direkt mit
Mit einer Config Map
Konfigurieren was das jetzt eigentlich ist
Wie macht man
Wie macht man eine Environment Variable
In Go
OS ich will nicht ZEnv
Ich will
Was
Das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst oder
Das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst
Ach ne geht doch
OS Get Env
Kann man Default Value übergeben
ne
Ja
Das kann
Das kann es jetzt auch fehlschlagen
Ich nimmt es einfach nur Name
Moment
OS Get Enf kann nicht fehlschlagen
Was ist denn wenns es nicht gibt
Ist es dann einfach leer oder was
Also gerade das hatte ich wirklich gedacht
Nicht es kann auch fehlschlagen
Weil es ja nicht angelegt sein muss
Das ist einfach
konsequent oder warum gibt so was nicht denn er jeder furz gibt in golden error aber nicht
existierte für ein weib und variable gibt mp string das heißt ich muss jetzt quasi checken
ja wobei eigentlich eigentlich ist das ist der name ist ist eigentlich required als wir durch
lupen ja eigentlich ist required kann man okay ich gehe davon aus dass ich sowas machen muss
oder gibt es auch so was wie not white space in go also wenn das wenn das gleich gleich dem
ist dann sagen wir hier lockt fatal sowie unten lockt fädeln geiler name für eine funktion lockt
fädeln keck 0 w größer keck wird das ist die beste fehlermeldung dafür ach so und dann
ist das ist die beste fehlermeldung dafür ach so und dann ist das ist die beste fehlermeldung dafür
error status ja nein das mache ich nicht aber da sieht man schön die go philosophie
jeden furz explizit schreiben was look up and what wo es look up and da gibt es den
bull zurück man warum nicht einfach einen error wie sonst überall anders auch look up and and
und jetzt hier wir können es doch erronter ist doch egal aber jetzt müssen wir nicht ungleichen
muss man muss man macht man so macht man das so oder kann man das irgendwie gleich in line
machen if not okay dann fällt er beim crash das gilt das finde ich jetzt wiederum ganz hübsch ehrlich gesagt das finde ich jetzt wiederum ganz hübsch ehrlich gesagt das finde ich jetzt wiederum ganz hübsch ehrlich gesagt
aber das ist gut da kann man das ganze direkt oder konflikt map einstellen aber das ist gut da kann man das ganze direkt oder konflikt map
einstellen einstellen
und dann exportiert da das auch immer mit dem tal wie gesagt das kann durchaus ja auch sein dass das eine ganz andere block chain
technology ist
okay nice
da haben ihr doch heute wieder was gelernt
der iq reward geht an den andreas der sich gut auskennt mit vom quell
was war das erste noch mal
Ich hab's schon wieder verdrängt.
Was war das erste Schlaue, was er geschrieben hat?
Äh, PromQL.
Such jetzt einfach.
Ah, Regex.
Grab.
Grab Pearl Regex.
Ja.
Probier mal if.
Was?
If name?
Okay.
Was?
What?
Achso, dann sagt er name.
Name is not.
Was?
Oh, oh, oh.
Was ist das?
Okay, Chatgear.
Was ist, was ist hübscher?
Oder was?
Würdet ihr, okay.
Würdet ihr es lieber mit einem if schreiben oder so?
Ist der Name dann nur in dem Blog?
Nö, glaub ich nicht.
Doch, ist nur.
Alter, das ist ja mal was, ey.
So?
Ich find das super hässlich, ehrlich gesagt.
Weil das Ding ist, ich will ja crashen, wenn es nicht geht.
Jetzt kann man sowas machen?
Ja, kann man.
Jetzt, jetzt kann ich hier crashen, ja.
Du schreibst auch Klammern in eigene Zeile.
Ja, weil das ist das Richtige.
Aber jetzt merkt er dann, dass es name nicht gibt.
Ja gut, das ist nicht schlimm.
Name würde ich ja hier unten benutzen.
Ja, die würde ich dann quasi hier einsetzen.
Äh.
Chatgear?
Wir machen das nicht so.
Weil wie soll ich jetzt auf name zugreifen?
Was, war?
Nö.
Nö, nö.
Mario, danke schön für den Sub.
Nö, nö, nö, das ist das Funst so nett.
Was, davor?
Nö.
Wie jetzt?
Nö, nö, nö, nö, nö, nö.
Nö.
Äh.
Sicher?
Nö.
Leute, das ist.
Das ist ja, also das ist ja sowas von wir.
Das machen wir nicht so.
Okay, ich muss gleich was.
Aber jetzt geht es mit dem okay nicht.
Nee, nee, das machen wir nicht.
Wir machen das weg und sagen if not okay.
Das ist, das ist die bessere Variante, Chat.
So wie wir es ursprünglich hatten, okay?
So, jetzt, jetzt findet er das nicht.
Jetzt sage ich export blockchain name gleich polygon run punst.
Und jetzt steht da, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Und jetzt steht auch polygon drin.
Sehr nice.
Und in unserem Grafana auch jetzt.
Ups.
Kack noob.
Ja.
Er hat es noch nicht, er hat es noch nicht gecrawled, glaube ich.
Warum kein Kibana?
Warum kein Telegraph?
Ich habe das, ich habe das ja nur hier eingetragen.
Ich habe das ja nur eingetragen bei Block ID.
Last Block ID.
Guck, jetzt steht blockchain Name dran.
Sehr cool.
Das finde ich nice.
Das kann man mehr oder weniger schon so morgen verwenden.
Naja, also vielleicht nicht ganz.
Ich sollte dort vielleicht nicht als Meldung lulwe kekwe und help kekel reinschreiben.
Aber so von der Idee her, finde ich das, finde ich das gut.
Ach ja, und das wird bei uns dann auch nicht so laufen.
Also ich werde auch keine Abfrage machen gegen Polygon Scan, sondern Abfrage gegen die interne API von der Node Software.
Wisst ihr, was mich verwirrt?
Hier, woher weiß der, was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen?
Ach so, weil es könnte ja ein Error sein.
Woher weiß der denn, dass das ein Int, woher weiß er, dass es ein Float64 ist?
Weil, ach Moment, es ist immer ein Float64, aber wenn ich hier 32 angebe, dann ist es auch ein Float64.
Jetzt verstehe ich den Sinn.
Der Bit-Size, ehrlich gesagt, nicht.
Ja, das wirkt ein bisschen hakelig, ja, das verstehe ich.
Warum gibt es kein Pass-Float32, ein Pass-Float64?
Warum gibt es so ein komisches Pass-Float, was immer ein 64, Returned, aber auch ein 32 oder ein 15 oder so sein kann?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Aber gut, immerhin funktioniert das ziemlich, ziemlich gut.
Gut.
Wollen wir hier gerade mal aufräumen.
Immerhin funktioniert das alles ziemlich gut.
Das gefällt mir.
Also ich würde, ich würde sagen, ich werde das morgen noch ein bisschen umbauen.
Da brauche ich noch ein Image drumherum.
Warum ist das vom Sprintende immer so stressig?
Weil ihr nicht diagonal skaliert habt.
Mit dem entsprechenden Hyperscaler.
Ja.
Zu wenige Mikro-Sprints zwischendurch.
Und ihr habt sicher nichts.
Wo bloß?
Best Practices befolgt.
Ihr habt bestimmt Sachen dokumentiert, oder?
Wenn ja, ist das das Problem.
Es muss funktionieren.
Es muss nicht dokumentiert werden.
Und auch noch, es wird ja immer schlimmer.
Guck mal, wie viel Manpower und Mannjahre und sowas da wieder gewastet wurden für Tests und Dokumentation.
Ja.
In der Retrospektive sollte das dringend sein.
Es sollte dringend angesprochen werden.
Also erstens immer diagonal skalieren.
Ganz richtig.
Korrekt.
Und es muss funktionieren.
Weil wenn es funktioniert, braucht es keine Tests, keine Dokumentation und sonst nichts.
Keine Maintenance.
Es funktioniert einfach.
Übrigens, Andreas, jetzt worauf ich eigentlich raus wollte.
Massive High IQ Five Head Messages heute.
Das muss man ja auch mal anerkennen.
Ich überweise Bezos einfach mal selbst 3,99 Euro gerade.
Von denen ich die Hälfte immerhin zurückbekomme.
Hat sich also richtig gelohnt, Subs zu giften.
Aber Sub giften lohnt sich nie.
Also für mich.
Wenn ich mir selbst, also wenn ich selbst auf meinem Channel jemanden in Sub gifte, lohnt sich das nicht.
Wäre ja auch blöd, wenn sich das lohnt.
Weil dann wäre das der Infinite Money Klitsch.
Würdest du dir einfach unendliche Subs selbst giften.
Ey, du hast heute nicht High IQ Five Head Messages.
Du hast nicht High IQ genug.
Moment, Moment.
Steuer wiederholen heißt nicht, dass man das eins zu eins wiederbekommt.
Nur wenn ich das angebe.
Wenn ich das angebe, dass ich irgendwie Werbekosten, was auch immer, wie man das dann nennt, habe.
Dann wirkt sich das insgesamt vielleicht ein bisschen auf meinen Steuersatz mini, mini, mini, mini malst aus, sodass ich, aber ich kriege das Geld dadurch nicht wieder.
Ja, ab nächstes Mal muss natürlich manuell selbst verlängert werden.
Das ist ja logisch.
Ja, komm, Leute.
Aus reiner Nächstenliebe.
Mach ich das ja auch nicht.
Komm in die Gruppe.
Ah, ja, ja.
Leute, ich werde noch zum richtigen Anime-Gucker.
Ich sag's euch.
Letzten Tage richtig viel Zeug geguckt.
Und warum?
Weil die ganzen Streaming-Dienste alle anfangen, mich abzufacken.
Deswegen streame ich mir jetzt einfach irgendwelche Animes, die ich ja alle nicht kenne, weil ich nie welche geguckt habe.
Großartig.
Und die Kampagnen.
Da kann man sich kostenlos streamen, ohne dass die irgendeinen Streaming-Dienste, kostenlose Grauzone, ja, ohne dass sich irgendein Streaming-Dienst abfuckt.
Amazon geht mir auf den Keks mit Werbung.
Netflix wird immer teurer, hat immer mehr Shit und fuckt mich allgemein schon lange ab.
Alles andere ist auch für den Arsch.
Und Anime-Sachen ist so Grauzone, weil es da kein, also oftmals halt keiner die Rechte irgendwie in Deutschland dran hat, gekaucht hat.
Nein, können wir nicht.
Können wir nicht.
Das wäre auf jeden Fall Monkatos.
Das wäre definitiv Monkatos.
Ja.
Naja, vielleicht.
Übrigens, Leute, mein Strike auf Twitch von Apple ist weg.
Schon seit einer ganzen Weile.
Ich wurde ja mal gestriked von Apple, beziehungsweise von einer Anwaltskanzlei, die im Auftrag von Apple agiert.
WSL2 ist POG.
Naja.
Wenn man sonst keine Möglichkeit für Linux hat, mag das POG sein.
Ja.
Weil Apple hat sich irgendwie ein Jahr später oder so, nachdem sie mich mal gestriked haben, dafür entschieden, dass es doch nice ist, wenn die Leute das auf Twitch streamen.
Apple braucht ja immer ein bisschen für sowas.
Und dann wurde mein Strike auch revoked.
Nee, Apple macht es nicht mehr.
Apple lässt die Leute jetzt streamen.
Zumindest die letzten Male immer.
Dafür ist WSA jetzt updated.
Was ist WSA?
Bist du Max FPS?
Ich bin Wobblors, Mann.
Windows.
Moment, das ist was?
Das ist outdated?
Ich hab nie mitbekommen, dass es überhaupt rauskommt.
Dass es überhaupt rausgekommen ist.
Jetzt haben die immer wieder verschoben.
Diese Android-Emulator-Geschichte für Windows.
Und jetzt ist es outdated, oder was?
Das hat niemand mitbekommen, dass es überhaupt existiert.
Naja.
Aber ja, du hast mich erwischt.
Ich bin das.
Und warum ich anders heiße?
Das ist auch einfach erklärt.
Also ursprünglich kommt es daher, weil der Account älter ist,
als ich vorhatte zu streamen.
Und ich nicht Max FPS.
Der Max FPS gehörte übrigens auch mir.
Ich könnte mich umbenennen, aber eigentlich will ich mich gar nicht umbenennen.
Weil es hat einen großen Vorteil.
Nur die High-IQ-Leute wie du kommen hier und checken das.
Und alle nervigen Leute von YouTube sind eh zu dumm und kapieren es nicht.
Also deswegen finde ich das mit zweitem Namen eigentlich ganz nice.
Aber allzu viele, ja, geistige Transferleistungen muss man ja auch nicht leisten.
Bei dem bescheuerten Namen und dem Avatar sollte es auch vielen klar sein, wenn sie es das erste Mal sehen.
Das gab es im Amazon App Store.
Ja gut, das benutzt ja auch niemand.
Warum gab es das nicht über WinGet wenigstens?
VMWare4M ist doch nice.
VMWare4M ist kein WSL.
WSL2 ist zwar unter der Haube eine Hyper-VVM.
Aber die Versuchskammer ist nicht so gut.
Die versuchen ja ganz viel Windows-Integration.
Du hast ja dort nicht irgendwie jetzt, wie bei mir, ein vollständiges Linux mit grafischer Oberfläche.
Wo du kaum noch einen Unterschied zu Native merkst.
Du hast ja nur die VM für Linux-Körnel und grafische Ausgaben gehen ja über Windows-Software.
Beziehungsweise über diese komische WSLG-Geschichte, die auch mehrere Probleme hat.
Also das Beste für mich ist...
Genau ist auf dem Host, auf dem zweiten Desktop, ein Linux mit VMWare.
Beste.
Interessiert dich?
Ja, das kommt die Tage raus, der zweite Teil.
Ja, ja.
Oder heute sogar.
Ist nicht mal lang.
Ja, und sogar auf YouTube steht sogar der Twitch-Account.
Ja, das kommt auch noch dabei.
Aber ich glaube, er ist schon wieder weg.
Ist er schon wieder weg?
Insta live oft.
Oder bist du noch da?
Jetzt, nachdem du mich exposed hast.
Ja, ich habe es mit Sway auch schon ausprobiert.
Sway geht bei mir nicht gescheit, weil Wayland in der VM nicht gescheit funktioniert.
Und Wayland immer noch Copy-Paste-Probleme hat.
Mit bestimmten...
Achso, Moment.
Nicht nur Copy-Paste-Probleme.
Der Screen refresht nicht.
Ich sehe nichts.
Aber man kann das irgendwie fixen, weil wenn du Gnome laufen lässt in Wayland und so,
dann funzt das komischerweise in der VM.
Aber Sway nicht.
Was haben wir heute gemacht?
Mit Golang?
Wir haben einen Prometheus-Exporter gebaut, der Blockchain-Sachen abfragt und bereitstellt als eigene Metriken.
Hast du dich damals auch schon mit Krypto beschäftigt?
Was ist damals?
Auf welchen Zeitpunkt?
Ich beschäftige mich eigentlich gar nicht groß mit Krypto.
Ich bin immer wieder erstaunt, wie viele Bullshit-Coins auf Twitter täglich trenden.
Ich beschäftige mich nur mit Krypto, was das Projekt auf meiner Arbeit angeht.
Und da ist weder hier Dogecoin noch die Dinger, die aktuell auf Twitter trenden dabei.
Also bist du kein Krypto-Millionär.
Unter Milliardär macht das nicht.
Bist du kein Krypto-Milliardär.
Das habe ich nicht gesagt.
Aber nein, ich bin kein Krypto-Milliardär.
Ich könnte sicherlich Milliardär in der Krypto-Währung sein, die nichts wert ist und dort in Zahlen Milliarden haben.
Aber bringt mir ja nichts, wenn es im Endeffekt keine Kohle für gibt.
Warum habt ihr euch für Blockchain entschieden?
Wurde das vorgegeben?
Wie erkläre ich das jetzt am besten?
Weil die auch coole Projekte machen wollen.
Mit irgendeiner Hype-Technologie.
Das Problem ist, dass das eigentlich schon gar nicht mehr gehypt ist.
Aber wenn sowas bei Versicherungen und Banken und Finanzbranche ankommt,
dann ist die Sache meistens schon outdated.
Die Sinnhaftigkeit erschließt sich mir auch nicht wirklich gerade.
Was die eigentlich da...
Also ich meine, ich weiß, was die machen wollen, ja.
Aber wie gesagt, die Sinnhaftigkeit erschließt sich mir nur so am Rande.
Aber soll mir recht sein,
ich finde es mega nice.
Das liegt weniger an der Krypto-Geschichte,
sondern was ich mit Google Cloud und allem drumherum bauen kann, finde ich sehr nice.
Und Kubernetes obendrauf.
Und jetzt auch demnächst noch Monitoring über Prometheus,
hier mit eigenem Exporter und sowas.
Also das hat schon einen Sinn, was wir hier gebaut haben.
Das wird mehr oder weniger so bei mir dann auf der Arbeit eingesetzt.
Ich meine, nicht mit gegen Polygon-Scan die Abfrage ins Internet
und auch nicht solche Unsinsmetriken,
aber im Prinzip sowas sehr ähnliches wird da eingesetzt.
Bei uns dauern Dailies 15 Minuten.
Für 11 Leute ist das zu viel.
Nee, das ist ziemlich gut.
In 10 Jahren machen wir KI.
Ja, also ich gehe davon aus, wir machen KI vielleicht in 5 Jahren schon.
Also wir machen aber KI auf jeden Fall erst, wenn der Hype vorbei ist.
Also ich finde 15 Minuten für 11 Leute sehr gut, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, ich kenne das auch.
Wir haben halt auch Leute gerne, die können ohne Probleme 30 Minuten Monolog halten,
aber beschweren sich dann, wenn...
wenn du mal zwei Sätze nicht mit ihnen wechselst, so.
Ja, also ich finde das ziemlich gut.
15 Minuten für 11 Leute.
Ich sage bei den meisten Dailies eh, dass ich nichts habe.
Dann ist man schneller durch.
Okay, 22.6 Leute.
Bettge-Time.
Ich habe das Ganze verpasst.
Ich habe was, Chat, und keiner von euch hat was gesagt.
Boomer müde, Boomer schlafen.
Bettge.
Nein, es ist das Stream.
Schön, dass ihr da wart.
Wir hören uns.
Ja, bald auf jeden Fall.
Wie bald, weiß ich nicht.
Vielleicht will ich, vielleicht baue ich morgen noch was an dem Exporter,
dann streame ich nochmal oder was anderes.
Aber morgen muss ich eigentlich MMO Kreiselgrind machen wieder.
Stellt euch mal vor, ich bin in dem MMO, wo ich spiele, in der Gilde,
und aus dem Nichts promotet mich einer zu Guildleader.
Die Begründung dafür war, du bist doch eh immer da.
Und das Dumme ist, in den letzten zwei Tagen gab es übelst Drama,
weil Leute auf dem Server irgendeine Scheiße gebaut haben aus,
naja, ist nicht wirklich meine Gilde.
Und ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock, mich mit Drama auseinanderzusetzen.
Ich habe jetzt zwei andere auch zum Gildenleiter befördert,
die können sich da drum kümmern.
So Drama-Sachen habe ich echt keinen Bock drauf.
Aber die haben das echt gut gemacht, muss man ihnen ja mal zugute halten.
Ich war ja nicht da die letzten zwei Tage.
Okay.
Ja, du hast es nicht ausgelöst.
Aber Katrig, ich kann dir erzählen, was war.
Du hast das Game ja auch gespielt.
Leute haben irgendwie, man kann nicht sagen, einen Bug ausgenutzt,
aber sagen wir mal, Vorteile ausgenutzt,
um mit acht Leuten, sagen wir mal, 70 Leute zu killen.
Die waren auf EV und haben PvP eingeschaltet,
was du ja machen kannst für Achtergruppen dort,
und haben die ganze Mit-BG gebombt.
Und du kannst dir ja vorstellen, der Ober-Malaka war sehr wenig erfreut darüber.
Aber man muss auch sagen, die haben sich auch Infos aus Discord und BG-Chat geholt
und haben dann direkt am richtigen Punkt gewartet und so.
Das war schon ziemlich assi-Aktion.
Ja, und anscheinend war der Crew-Leader aus meiner Gilde.
Und ich war nicht da und sie haben sich alle übelst aufgeregt.
Ja.
Sie haben zwei andere Leute befördert, die noch öfters da sind als ich.
Jetzt ist alles gut.
MMO-Drama-Beste.
Ich finde das immer geil.
Das erinnert mich immer so an 2003 oder so, wo ich viele MMOs gespielt habe.
Okay, Chat, jetzt bin ich ja wirklich off.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.